c'est parti on est en direct dans
quelques femmes qu'un bail mais bon à
force de faire l'idiot avec fabre s'est
en plus fait signer le f tu vois c'est
on
on veut pas donc on est parti on est
parti laurent on est parti pour
3h15 3h20 de la rive est ce que tu es
prêt je suis tout à fait prêt on est en
direct on en direct à est en direct la
jolie taclant ok donc bonjour tout le
monde la tata d'état des milliers de
personnes ils sont là florent freyssinet
tu vois ils comprennent plus seulement
des milliers de suivre ces démissions
ouais je sais pas je dis ans
grandissante de bli stream de ses titres
à les voir à tout ce dont tu te vois le
chat à je vois tout on est en départ
fait je vois nakamura qui bouge plus en
fait l'image qu'ils avaient qui est
bloqué à reste et l'image qu'ils étaient
bloqués à ennery les lunettes rouges
maintenant tu as ta machine
je vous en fait qu'est ce que c'est que
ce bordel le cherche-midi ville est
aussi horrible personnage mais il est
trop quel frime
qu'est ce que c'est que ce à quoi ouais
c'est n'importe quoi
ouais c'est n'importe quoi il est puni à
les maxima vas-y puni lui ses lunettes
il ventait l'info qui commence fort et
qui termine fort
ouais c'était des gros commentaires hors
antenne parce que le bullet il est pas
vraiment favoris en bullet et avancer à
s'équilibrer c'est ça ouais bon
équilibre et à quel point la ratons sas
lance je dois juste faire un petit sur
l'appel 1re sting sur la chaîne et mitry
parce que là on est sur la chaîne chaise
comme et on va pouvoir commenter donc là
laurent pour le moment oif
tu commences envoie l'échiquier je sais
pas tu te bats quoi le maire a priori la
mieux purgé six donc à une bonne semelle
donc voilà on va voir il a décidé de
testeurs c'est ce qui est bien et maxime
c'est qu'ils jouent ces ouvertures
habituel même sur ce point comme sur
montreuil bros d'idées mais en gros il
ya sur un adversaire vas-y mon trop
mince quotas moi j'ai confiance sur
malgré une faible sur un âge d'or et
montre moi ta prépa donc voilà il joue
une petite variante fou j'ai cinq tours
c'est un aspect très dangereux mais bon
il a probablement préparé pour quelques
parties dans le match je me souviens
maxime va pas être va pas être très
forcément sur ça je connais pas très
bien c'était malheureusement davantage
pour maxime laurent quand tu vraiment
toujours la même ouverture c'est vrai
t'as pas peur que les mecs tu sors des
nouveautés ou quoi de toute façon tu oui
c'est ça assez souvent dans la douleur
comme ici à peut attraper la partie
comme magnus à vienne tu vois je suis
bien placé pour pour en parler du coup
il s'éprend passe très bien passé dès
l'ouverture pour magnus mais tu vois il
arriva il sent très bien les positions
ils les jouent très bien ses positions
et donc il a réussi à s'en sortir et
même plus que ça ils étaient gagnants il
a raté un gain mais bon qui était dur à
voir après un rush a appris l'ap
artistes d'autres mais tu te tu te
doutes que j'ai fait une vidéo
oui évidemment c'est bien là il faut que
je règle macapa pas alors attends c'est
peut-être moi c'est peut-être moi qui
dois non elle va bien t'inquiète pas tu
es bien non pas tu te vois pas ça va non
je sais pas on va écouter c'est un
monsieur qui me l'a jamais dit pavin
sûrement un envers la voilà donc je sais
pas le coach a un peu recadré comme ça
mais quand c'est de ces deux voilà c'est
gourmand donc plus important c'est de
voir les joueurs on voit les joueurs on
va tous en mairie lunettes rouges c'est
quand même spécial
enfin genre qu'est ce que c'est que ces
périodes où j'étais donc que sur f3 et
le foin f3 doucement voilà et il reprend
le fou tu souris quoi que ce soit bref
trois y aurait pas de ma carte à non il
y aurait d'abord d'avoir à quatre baies
5 intermédiaires et il a fait des deux
voilà pour des coups et mellal et les
blancs rien paraître on peut faire
flouer f3 non on peut fabriquer prendre
quatre oui ok pour les quatre qui
menacent d'ailleurs donc la praille
on va apprendre on vous prend 2,2 mais
tu gardes le carignan des 4 es tu match
les lensois quand même que je viens de
clients des 4 parce que la dame prend
les finales sont durs en fait dame croit
il faudrait être atteint damas cinq
dames des deux je suppose et les finales
sont un peu dur ça va être un pourquoi
pourquoi c'est dur en fait du christ
qu'il a fait
des données jacquot l'homme c'est tout
simplement il a fait fou des deux voilà
je vous dis dans ma cave peut-être sur
dam des deux dames à quatre avec l'idée
de daglan larissa
ouais mais tire offre donc peut-être la
finale il vit tout at-il prôné en d2 en
fait ils prenaient en d2 il jouait 3,17
et ours et 8 il a dû estimer qu'il est
atteint pour faire ça c'est une partie
importante en le rendant très sains
ouais les leçons des matches seront donc
mais il réfléchit à roc la tour 7 /
europe qui va sur la la 7e qui attaque
de pions et surtout avec avec les noirs
faut surtout pas perdre cette parce
qu'après l'occurrence le plombier est
passé et pas de permis pas vraiment
échanger à 2 contre les bombers loin ils
les connaissent et position maxime enfin
là il réfléchit il m'a l'air d'être sous
pression quand même alors il est sous
pression clairement les blancs le petit
avantage mais qu'est ce tu peux faire
d'autre que rock en fait du coût final
parce que je fais par contre vous il
reprend des pions métier mais on veut
pas prendre plus riad mb cinq échecs
franchement c'est un autre il l'a fait
rock il est parti sur un comme ces cas
là tu n'as qu'à moi veut faire de moi je
jouais d'homs et 4 et 6 mais c'est pas
un coût de l idée de prendre à kuan
cécile fait dame prend tout reprend il y
avait foule et c'est ce soit ait été
influencée par magnus non tu as une
magouille site aiguë je fais des finales
au maximum donc je jouerai le coup sûr
mais je vais te dire un truc mais c'est
pas pour ses pas pour te caresser dans
le sens du poil mais un peu quand même
c'est que j'ai beaucoup progressé après
avoir étudié
enfin vous semi étudié tu dis c'est un
grand mot mais les parties de magnus en
fait ça m'a donné plus de compréhension
de profondeur j'adore vraiment son jeu
en fait c'est wayne bien sûr reste dense
et très profond stratégiquement et il
n'a pas du tout le même style que de la
cas où maxime même nom c'est c'est
différent comme je l'aï aidé à me france
et 8 et 17 rien qu'avant mais tu as le
site de magnus il est peut-être plus
facile faire à moindre niveau 1 à à à
à copier pour un amateur parce que c'est
moins tactique c'est plus possesseurs de
la carte pop
tu vois la pop et 6 passes et de bas
mais il était en difficulté toute la
partie comme difficultés mais il a mal
moi je pensais que c'était plutôt par la
sortie de l'ouverture mais tout prendre
en réseau c'était un peu bizarre alors à
tandis que le titre de la vidéo est pas
le bon bout peut-être faire que j'allais
chercher mon autre ordi je te laisse
commenté une petite une petite minute
l'an d'accord bien patrimoine donc on
voit une une italienne on va en voir
certainement beaucoup
il a peur des bas rhinois sur maxime ses
coups normaux là les noirs jouent à cinq
dans le massif c'est plus normal mais ça
c'est là c'est la nouvelle idée pour
prendre deux spéciales dame juste je
suis tout simplement empêché b4 un fou
des singles il va prendre en faire
cavalier ou cette dame mais huit damas
est alors ça c'est aussi c'est assez
nouveau
ce genre de plan et c'est assez
intéressant pour les noirs c'est très
jouable pas peur de partir du centre
avec avec tadam
c'est risqué mais écoutez f2 qui est
faible car il faut avoir les affaires
des massettes est aussi et surtout à 4
adp 5
c'est assez intéressant comme donc
système fou trois là il peut prendre et
jouer cavalier hausse est en fait à
damas et passionnel passible d'un v6
plus ou moins ici pour prendre b2 voilà
il vous faut à 4 comment empêcher
ouais non sinon le tt revenus la découpe
ouais je suis fait j'étais semi la hache
la cendrée ça et je suis là je suis
nouveau là je suis nouveau à fond
pourquoi maxime a peur d'abella news
parce qu'il sait ccc c'est très dur de
ses tirs trouver des idées contre bas
rhinois c'est le sait le haut niveau et
la finale donne pas grand chose et les
autres systèmes non plus donc les gens
jouent des italiennes pour essayer
d'avoir une position avec beaucoup de
pièces comme on le voit ici bon mais
aussi l occasion harkis et d'échanger
une et un léger avantage des espaces
parce que c'est un peu plus facile pour
les blancs de jouer de jouer des quatre
de prendre un peu d'espacé un peu plus
confortable qu'une étude explique très
bien dans la vidéo qu'on a mis en ligne
ce matin laurent d'ailleurs
oui oui je te remercie et j'essaie de
faire du mieux que je pouvais mais du
coup moi j'ai pas joué dit et en fait je
j'aimerais jolie italienne et j'ai
vraiment un score lamentable c'est un
peu pareil que l'anti berlinoise
pourtant et oui oui non mais je pense
que c'est bon signe mais je perds et non
mais tu vois j'ai un très mauvais score
j'ai perdu j'ai perdu quelques parties
et j'avais gagné très peu donc vous
devez manger arrêter tout simplement ça
c'est comme la raddho zine j'aime
beaucoup les magazines mais je perds à
chaque fois donc on sait pas s'il y
envoie 28 sont très bien toute la partie
super à chaque fois oui non j'aime bien
l'ouverture j'aime bien les possessions
mais je perds donc bah du coup je joue
et l'espagnol jaime bien meilleur score
il a pris adresse que c'est que ça n'en
attends c'est ok sur b3 veut faire b5
oui il a trop fréquentés sont en fait
c'est ça le problème
c'est un coup que magnus envisagerait
pas c'est exactement en parler et
maintenant il ya eu quatre ans pressé
seul pour la haye a taxé 3
la dame s'est envolé il ya probablement
été dans le processus est tant mieux
fargues et objets de revient et le cari
et là c'est pas terrible
bon c'est à ces gars là maintenant et
plus trop de choses et on voit que les
deux pions c3 v3 sont maintenant d'aider
des cibles pour un tour tu vois tu as
deux tours de colonnes à l'option
étaient en fait des pieds et des mains
pour réussir pas vu mais moi j'avais vu
mais je n'ai rien dire je m'en fous mais
pas passer pour un con j'ai la tête du
cac radio 4 le retour à bombay le kansas
leur retour tu vas aller à pied c'est
après je te prends le 5
du coup tu reviens on regarde quand même
pointu mais où j'ai fait retour des 8 à
mon avis oui parce que là il est bien
maxime donc il a fait une combine en
bois en fait hein ça marcherait pas du
tout mais ça se comprend ça fait pas la
gueule du bon coup enfin c'est fait
c'est vraiment un bon coup mais maxi
n'avait pas vu ça à peu près clair mais
c'est vrai que c'est le genre de truc
qui marche avec voilà il a en plus en
plus maintenant bon évidemment des
chances 2 nuls 1 pour les noirs mais
désagréable
est-ce que tu échange des idées avec les
normes pas
si j'essaie de faire marcher au 4 à tout
prix bons cavaliers aux quatre essais de
faire marcher carioca donc a priori
cette dame se fera un métronome b2
je masse des 5èmes avec les blancs donc
là il va falloir prendre je pense à elle
je fais des 5 c 4 c'est fini ça va faire
un beau tour s'est vite d'abord dans ces
vies turquie puis en prendre cinq sa
perte est prendre maintenant à 4 as pas
bête
mais comment il fait en fait c'est quoi
le jeu peut prendre 5 mais il fait à
trois il prétend que son pion à 2 et
d'envoi des trucs sous pression mais
peut-être faire dame donc le coup
intermédiaire bahamas et devrait il
menace le cas tu me l'as eu cinq en fait
cela ouais j'aime bien ça sur tf6 iv p
reprend 1,5 tout simplement dame b 7e
rang à 4 maintenant c'est bon il ya deux
ans de plus c'est simple ça a gagné ou
ça reste oui hélas la ségalière ces
gagnants après c'est simple tu vois
notre image des flandres je peux pousser
ses katas par exemple maximy fait pas
crédit peut-être way fait ces cas tout
simplement allongé emporté bien placé il
ya du cavaly m5 qui va arriver là je
sais pas de quoi il reprend mais en
général oui c'est gagnant s'il ya aucun
doute
cavaillé prend à sa manière logique
menace kalyev 5 mai khai des six après
s'est passé par game story 4 5 rbds et 5
à tempo cavaliers f5 par les attentions
yahia l'autre cavalli qui veut venir des
cinq caïds et si ça met plus d'âme siens
3 aussi qui peut arriver laurent là il
doit faire dmb 3 alors c'est ce que je
pensais de mme b 3 le pur à 4 et quand
même pas facile à des formes ensuite pas
mal joué dam des trois mais peut-être tu
peux prendre effet requis des cinq quand
même ce que tutorat des kabyles 16 même
si les cinq je bouge
oui je le dois bouger alors j'ai pensé 4
qui avait si ça tu te fais ouais c'est
bien son papa mal placée en fait il
initia le cavalier la iihf fourchette
basse et jolie pas exact mais ça tient
pas selon wayne et maxime qui prend son
temps quand même un lit pas il veut pas
déserter il à 2,30 à près de deux ans
dans les matchs que j'avais regardé à
chaque fois c'était serré au début et à
un moment donné maxime commencé à gaffer
sur une deux parties et du coup ça va
être un il a gaffé au départ il y avait
mis les ratés de la france évite
largement abordable pour un joueur 1
l'ex comptable en tactique va pour la
prochaine pas répartir la prochaine
partie on changera le joueur qu'on suit
si j'avais suivi n'a cassé que maxime
s'est connecté en dernier laurent et du
coup je suis du côté de nadal on va
faire un petit changement la partie
d'après donc là il améliore sa position
ok c'est pas si simple tu pas essayer de
faire du qui se joue à essayer de
bouffer ça en fait et des six mois ce
cavalier ou cet écueil problème c'est
pas moi qui ai dit si ça me plaît bien
tu protèges c4 aussi ouais mais
peut-être qu'il veut faire mieux par sa
manière très forte des six
ça a l'air pas mal hein tu peux avoir
des fourchettes de partout on sait pas
après et des six cavaliers aussi ce
peut-être regarde donc il veut prendre
leur paquet des six maintenant voilà il
fallait d'abord parce que sinon sur
calvillo 6 sur le recueil des cia
cabello 6 et sur cet hiver aux écrits ok
donc hélas il n'a pas voulu laisser le
temps de bouger sa gouaille fidhop 7 mai
il reprend ses quatre derrière moi si je
fous le roi est faible aussi le roi n'en
est très faible non mais juste llp dans
cette position mais il se défend bien
quand même pénible ça il est là il a
charrié la camorra c'est ça qui est
pénible quand ce genre de joueur laurent
soit je n'arrive jamais à les battre en
fait c'est que en fait même le jour où
par malou par miracle j'ai une position
gagnante
de toute façon la différence tu dois
gagner la partie tellement de fois en
fait les voix c'est ça c'est très dur
très dur de partir mais tu sens vraiment
une différence avec les mecs au dessus
de 2007
bien sûr non mais en plus c'est même pas
c'est quasi 2008 ambrilia déjà 2008
nakamura donc oui mais non mais c'est
sûr c'est encore pire j'ai jamais la
chance de jouer contre ces joueurs là tu
vas perso mais j'imagine que déjà à 2007
hors droits c'est la croix et la
bannière progrès en fait deux points ne
s'est pas d'avoir des bonnes oppositions
c'est l'heure des bois de position c'est
faisable mais après pour gagner ils se
défendent ses fans comme des bêtes
ingénieurs là ils sont pénibles
bien que quand ils jouent contre eux que
des fois ils font n'importe quoi moi ya
beaucoup de mieux le cas maintenant
oui mais parfois l'art du graff
franchement parfois droite a vu neuf
parties de sauve mais tu te relèves pas
attention au dire de quoi c'est quoi
cette italienne et 2 catalan
l'impression qu'ils voulaient 2,9 olam
est reparti en fait je suppose un peu
bizarre à tomber de lille s'active dans
les bouquins défense active donc ne me
restera deux il ya un mât sommet c'est
normal mais il mérite quand même le
pauvre pas les gens j'aimerais faire un
truc genre car alief cette bouffée c5
effet retour 8 pour essayer de jouer
pour marc remarquera gc sa chacra
artistique
tu pourrais faire ton enfin tu pour y
penser en tout cas fait qu'à l'époque 7
1 ouais m'a dit vas y vit depuis peu lui
placer le sait peut faire baby marathon
d'accord il l'est il ya du jeu là c'est
te faire f 3 ar et bêtement ouais mais
ça s'est pas bien passé là bas alors à
temps et peut-être faire tourner les
charismes et bizarre mais dans lequel il
s'était assez bizarre pas messi fait
tour à tour à vis de thaksin ont exigé
qu'elle débute avec l'idée de ma fille
mais c'était au projet de ligne à la il
est là quoi passer moche qui peut à
perdre maintenant alors attendre au sein
qui se passe quoi ya pas vu et l'a pas
vu ou aller sur 4 ha dont 85
alors attends je vais parce que j'ai
fini la jouer très vite un regard ce que
je vais faire c'est de la magie laurent
je vais arrêter de suivre la partie et
on va on va suivre on va suivre maxime
d'accord ensuite côté maxime teixeira
mieux quand même à un accord au québec
c'est plus sympa donc il refait la même
chose là du coup tous les gens qui vit
c'est la chatte à maxime fecteau maxime
il n'a pas très bien joué ouais mais ça
c'est bien le milieu de jeu était bien
et après il a un peu lâché politique
mais la carte est complètement surpris
si c'était quand même un peu plus il a
joué thème pour il n'était pas obligé
quoi il pouvait attendre trop vite pour
se défier lave la qualité à tanger med
gym un petit coup de caméra qu'on puisse
voir laurent ce que nous on n'a pas pu
s'enfuir à caméra non mais les grimaces
de naka ccam inoubliable donc fou 3 il a
joué je vais [ __ ] war vient et 1,5 et
dans sa tête même bizarre votre one
assure claude il y avait une foule et 4
c'est ça la partie d'avant ok donc c'est
un cas qui change au 1er mai il a enlevé
ses lunettes
laurent d'accord ok ça devait le gênait
aurait pu lui dire tout de suite tu vois
il avait pas fan des maîtres avaient
bien lisse et il a voulu se donner un
style il sait pas il joue avec les
lunettes de soleil et une fois comme
magnus il a fait ça là à san luis
ouais voyons simplement l'idée aux
couettes tu donnes occurrence est normal
dans les grandes chaînes
gérard cavaillé prend qui comprend fou
prend il à damas cinq échecs et bonjour
je montre son leader mais je jouais
droit de et ça va pas donc bon c'était
dematic donc cavalier aux deux en fait
trop tu as l'air juste ça va là le pion
pas ses protégés c'est pas très
important dans laurent va il est très
actif les noirs sont pas développées du
tout non il veut jouer un rôle de war
telle phrase tome 8 allée f 3 tours
prend 1,4 peut aussi peut-être faire
dame prend 1,2 et chacun
pour ces deux peut-être gérer sans alice
le roy f3
c'est un peu bizarre bref 3,3 alimentée
de maxime c'est quand même faut l'avoir
bien raccrocher un oui fallait oser tour
aux huit ont envie que je te retourne
vite normal tour 8f 33.4 non oui mais je
vois pas je vois pas ce qui ce dit faire
quoi sur un je comprends pas ce qui nous
fait rentrer et surtout huit fonds
projet 7g tourcoing quatre noms ouais je
croirais royal trois fous g4 pareil 3,10
3,20 ff5 temps figé le désarroi mais
j'ai une découverte
il fait tour est vite qu'ils aiment le
goût que tu as envie de jouer à tempo
mais c'est normal de prendre du temps tu
vois c'est juste un an plus une gare
réfléchit pas loin du minutes sur ça
mais c'est quand même moment un mac a
quand même très important face ici joue
contre le mois peut-être ce qu'il est
mais à mon avis là n'a vraiment pas
pensé je pense qu'il a juste paru si
génial sur wave 3 tu pourrais même faire
fou j'ai quatre échecs roi prend il pour
2004 mais tu fais bouger cadres et qui
fait bouger car la turquie relève trois
jeux mais ben ça ça va pas ça va arriver
à royat peut-être damas trois n'ont rien
ou trois mois non je pense que là on
fait des ibères sont venus de pernant
non mais c'est quand sera ordinaire
c'est quand même spécial la manière de
jouer dans wii alors qu'il ya des dames
crainte c'est ce que je veux na 6 6 sur
dam des trois tu vois je pensais à coups
de com dam des trois je fais deux points
à 2 j'ai créé tour ces deux et je fais
dame prenait 5 a épousé 4 marché cannois
série noël ouais ouais c'est ça promis
comme promis un bouton en forme ce soir
laurent ouais on va les coûts qui seront
ou alors c'est eux qui sont
particulièrement pas en forme c'est un
des deux mais j'avais maxime enfin la
pole au mans c'est vrai qu'ils carouge
suis pas je suis pas impressionné la cfu
thème des deux dames assises damage
quatre matches abandons à notre-dame 3
même la hisba assez bien joué dans le 3
way
en même temps s'il faisait pas ça il
abandonnait ça va pas bien loin on
apprend de damas
et s'inquiète adoption de plus meilleur
roi alors merouane d'adp d'assez loin
qu'elles ouais il abandonnait bijoux
mais il est vraiment pas en formica
renoncement enfin je sais pas la cie va
se remettre non on n'espère pas évident
a lancé s'est pas préparé ou quoi en
fait tu vois c'est bizarre c'est
carrément il tombe dans une prépa et et
il faut y réagit je vous le trouvez plus
tendue être son rang le 2ème étrange
mais c'est spécial et c'est très spécial
dont qui jouent encore écoute il n'a pas
tort dans le sens où peut-être qui se
dit si ça se passe pas très bien que
c'est en bullet qui peut faire la
différence donc tu as il ya le chrono tu
sais comment ça fonctionne alors en est
là mais bon c'est pas très optimiste 1
comme truc tu vois ou de jass combien il
reste une heure huit l'a25 plus à fait
d'accord il ya plus une heure en fait
y'a un gros hélas deux heures et demie
c'est spécial la stratégie
voilà qui peut charger les dab la dame
des deux dames 3 d'apprentis on prend
tout reprend dé 5,8 alors sa famille
elle dames 1 il ya eu 3 qui est faible
plus peut-être que ce que tu fais avec
les blancs là c'est que tu essayes de te
mettre en forme qui n'est que tu joues
une position perdante mais juste pour te
chauffer je ne sais pas je crois qu'il
joue un par des piles ice et 5 c'était
un carrier s'est dit mais la tête sous
l'eau ses manches et sac à chaque année
et nos pays on était mal avec quatre
lettres qui peut arriver à 4 h 5 bien
joué et bien joué mais son profil à un
tour g1 tour est 4e tour preuve de
courage l'emprise derrière je suis
d'accord c'était la partie du temps
c'est pathétique
salah tu peux tu va s'étaler
des élèves débutants en quoi tu peux la
faire en cours vraiment magnus tu vas
faire là faire du majin mais ça m'a
glissé de rigoler en voyant les regardes
tu penses le match pas sûr parce qu'elle
la coupe d'europe là il est en cours
doivent donc énormément il aime bien
regarder un bon après on avait regardé
un match c'est pas rognant avec son
chien qui aboyait là contre ghetto où je
sais pas quand je regardais un truc ça
lui plairait qui pensent qu'on va le
revoir l'année prochaine on pense à rien
encore pour le côté comme là bas il est
trop fort non mais c'est sûr qu'il est
fin des qui joue il est tellement favori
mais contre gries tous qu'il a un peu
souffert l'an dernier quand même c'était
un beau match
donc là il change pourquoi il change sur
l'italienne ça lui plaisait pas bon et
jeune karo kann en cacao code active
avec g5 double idée des noirs c'est de
faire dame ses sept fous j'ai cette
drogue aux petits roquets abscisse
envoie en fonction de gens s'ils
envoient tout à l'heure c'est ça c'est
ça il faut des 3 il se retrouve à jouer
un peu comme dans une française mieux en
effet adjugé 5 ça fait peut-être un peu
too much non des casses faible c'est
très très content et il faut qu'il
arrive à déstabiliser par exemple sur
foot est roi il peut prendre et je le
paye ses six probablement il n'y a pas
de calais 3 passes kg capitaux mais je
ne pense pas que ce soit eric dans cet
ordre de couple ken ses deux essais de
c'est bizarre c'est pas dans l'esprit du
truc qui est ici ce qu'est le roi bon ça
c'est trop bizarre c'est bizarre mais
ces positions que maxime a le plus de
mal à jouer dans une position ferme et
comme ça oui peut-être il a fait un truc
un peu marre en plus il vient de quand
même new york ou les deux qui étaient
massés faut pas laisser la bête respirez
un bon bien sûr mais les senneurs
français encore plus en faisant des
trucs un peu un peu bizarre bon là il va
jouer comment fabien aime pas du tout
quand tu fais ces cas dans les
françaises
ouais soit il fait b 5 à 5 et ils
essayent de foule g6 ouais mais vu que
t'as pas le tap a joué 2 à 3 ni rien
gérant c'est pas le plan le plus mans
après comme tu as quand même passer les
fous devant la structure de pions qui
sait ouais il real si cela je pense tout
à se faire flasher 5 peut-être parfois
ça empêche tout ça a pas mal quoi jeter
un verre ça que j'aime bien parce que
[ __ ] des trois je vais jouer pour un
prêt tu repartiras par là bas c'est
compliqué ses positions comme si
c'étaient les c4 j'aime pas je pense
qu'il fait qu'ils jouent dame c7 et vous
g7 et cisco avait d abord parce que
c'est un peu tôt j'ai en tout cas dans
la vie et ils te dis que c'est mauvais
c'est sûr d'accord mais ouais non j'en
sais rien je suis pas sûr qu'il soit
aussi perd en top 20 qui peut s'asseoir
à notre table tu vois ce soir pour le
moment on dit tous les coups laurent
ripart tout cas d'aidé en fait dès que
10 des coûts et qui sont pas jouées
l'appareil ont fait plus de dix cars ou
bon tu dis tu dis les plans des qui ne
joue pas comme toi c sont des erreurs on
sent que 20 va-t-on se jouer l'année
prochaine tu vas t'on se jouer l'année
prochaine laurent en demi-finale il ya
quelqu'un qui veut se faire censurer la
sueur au chat
la quarantaine de rappel des mots est
soudé des souvenirs les olympiades à
laurent le match contre l'hapoël donc
alors on va plaire à ses fans encore une
défaite c'est la censure tout de suite
je peux un jeu peut censurer mois il a
très bien joué cette partie mon
adversaire je ne peux pas toucher de la
voiture elles sont dures à jouer
d'ailleurs j'en parle et une maxima pour
la partie me disais que c'était dur à
jouer ses positions et que ça pouvait
tourner très vite il fait une petite
erreur soit respectée
qu'est ce que tu as regardé notre
débrief sur ta partie dans les coutumes
je suis pas complètement maso non mais
si vous voulez apprendre des choses sur
un contre l'âge des infos oui mais si tu
m'as dit beckham plus tôt mais je pense
avoir pas du tout c'est le fou pas mal
et que je te dois
mais je crois que ça marche pas en fait
pour pas qu'ils repartent en hausse est
tranquille et encore on s'est tu fais bk
je suis trouvé 6 après tu joues ton truc
bon mais je vais pas faire pousser cette
année c'est cissé je vais de surcharger
ans un bail à des partis comme ça est
bon selon les blancs mais bien un truc
où ils ont joué ces quatre aussitôt une
partie pas mal mais bon tu pourra jeter
un oeil le joueur de gérard d un truc
j'ai une petite amélioration mais bon
donc là il est il est bien là le foot
est roi c'est un mauvais coup des 360 et
je peux pas laisser ce soin aux cinq ans
sk des 9 3 qui marche ou pas deux mais
trois tours h7 seul coup on pourra
toujours échangé après lorie te faire
des ouais non pas du carré de 3 kg 4
après sur un truc d'artistes derrière
trois tours à cette dame prend des cinq
est aussi selon moi ce match j'en prenne
cette attention si la dame classe et un
peu trop mais c'est joli éléphants comme
en relief 6 pour cavaliers m6 et c'est
terminé
bref c'est 3 17 si ça marche assez joli
ouais mais ça va pas chômer
mais c'est les pédales le problème si un
jour on tu fais des partis en stream
une fois que tu as vu un truc comme ça
tu es obligé de le jouer tu vois enfin
nous on a une règle si c'est un mois
quand il fait un coup de défense
oui mais bon après tu perds mais tu es
tu en dis que tu as été plus dans
l'esprit que lui il ya donc quelque part
c'est toi qui a quand même gagné si tu
veux par par cas où je sais pas si tu
essaies tu vois mais il son horaire ces
sacrifices la locale prenez ça qu'ils se
regardent bon il marche pas encore parce
qu'il ya puis on prend à temps vas-y cac
et prend des 5 comprend au 6 6 km à 6
géo cette manne à calais franche
récupère la pièce et je donne bien ouais
bah tu vois il se regarde ces sacrifices
c'est sûr que maxime les regarde presque
l'impression qu'il prendrait sa qui
peuvent à faire un contre que j'allais
prendre 5 par exemple si je jouais g4 à
la rigueur tu m'as inscrits pour un f6
quand même ouais mais a fait un coup de
dams est par exemple stocks stratégiques
mentez pas très bien quand on coupe b3
baby boom vie à trois mois sur le long
terme la colombie ne peut pas utiliser
parce qu'elle se fout de cases blanches
qui est assez fort il ya joué qu'il
prenait
japhet d'accord ok mais je pense qu'il
faut qu'il le fasse
enfin il faut qu'il fasse quelque chose
de concret tu vois après ça ce qui est
prôné 5 ou autre chose
peut-être je pense qu'il peut reprendre
25 l'autre moi c'est ce que je regarde
vraiment d'accord et dépensez vous
prendre d'apprentissage ehdaa même
système et je souhaite cette position
enfin il n'est pas besoin de moi pour
toi c'était un peu le commentaire oui
pourquoi
six cas merci beaucoup donné donc cette
maintenant seul coup maintenant je veux
faire cavalier prend et fuji ci servait
ou cahiers de l'es6 colmatée mais sa
tour en achète à les dégâts à long terme
quand même si tu réussis à lui faire du
tout revers est faite voici un jour tu
réussiras ya fou oui mais si un jour tu
réussis à échanger le fou c'est fini
bonne chance pour preuve cette gymnaste
au 8 mai a gagné alors parce que sept
étaient quand même tu vois ça doit y
c'était davantage blanc savait pas si
t'es un gros avantage blanc mais cet
avantage pour problème c'est ok mais à
ce qu'il soit vraiment mieux là n'ont
peut-être cavadee kf1 kg 3 pour colmater
j'en ai marre de la non en fait oui
l'eau douce est je pense si bizarre ce
qui est de trier pas du tout s'est tu
sais pas comment apprécier du blitz à
duras tour aux 6 alors à ce moment là
toi fuite non et loire sont mieux aussi
avec les deux pièces ça c'est toujours
mieux point noir d'un bon jeu de pièces
voiture et filles pour un coût auquel on
fait attention la tête des quatre
d'abord j'ai 40 ans + 101 vitré au
carélie de revenir un jour
mais même pas sûr même pas sûr de g4
taux refi direct mosquée le 4s que tam
ti cats aussi une option
oui en chine un peu toujours échange les
dames série d'objets qui va faire une
une alerte away cela m'allait
fantastique fois c'est le maillage entre
duda ça va vraiment être le match à
avoir un cf ça va envoyer
[Rires]
toi je suis dames c'est ça être leur sol
je vais faire tout rage suite d'un match
c'est encore amel ouest a alors commenté
change
abel tout de suite faire ce que tu fais
cavaliers am3 am3 mais c'est quoi ce
résident sur toi et toi comment ils
protègent qu'un voyage 5 juste ouais le
cavalier dominé ouais je te rentre avec
la tour en des huit je te fait de tomber
8b de tavernost sur toute la tour
blanche à elle fera le matin peut
bloquer quoi que le bug très bloqués je
pense que là il réfléchit qui a sacrifié
le pion pas je pense qu'il n'a pas
besoin pourquoi il faut pas que ça et h5
tour au cices peut-être histoire de
d'attaquer les cavaliers toi de te un
empêcher at perds tu vois pas ce que
c'est toujours trois coups un peu actif
c'est terminé dois je crois d'abord avec
toi je crois sur balles et six sur les
flèches rouges et 6 alors je suppose
qu'il va faire tour aussi son cavalier
h3 peut-être toronto martin je n'ai pas
du tout et tout ramener au pays tu vois
il occupe sur tourbe et vite
probablement il a tout réussi ça swingue
c'est pas si clair les noirs sont mieux
peut-être qui l'a fait roi f6 du coup
ouais si c'est un couple n'a envie de
jouer sans réfléchir
mais quand le match est tendu ce temps
du lot non pas trop
les noirs sont quand même très bien
parce qu'ils ont trente secondes
d'avancé une demi heure plus tôt rue tu
surpris quand même ils à tours 1 h 4
elle est tellement aux fraises à il peut
prendre quatre cavaliers capter français
3 et
ben ouais nan mais les frappes annuel de
cession ont réussi ce nom mais ça peut
tenir laurent
je n'y crois pas avec une tour comme ça
aux fraises moyens fait retour à chaque
tour à chantourner am et tous les 6,6
couvre mais les menaces khalef 6 4 donc
faut faire quelques jeux truqués de f3
tout relâchement réussi ce qu'aucun
produit ne va pas l'air très étrange
événement
il protège quatre pays lui poser
problème
il ya plus de temps au maximum bijoux
prix moi j'ai six ou c'est risqué ça
soit 1 c'est pas si simple
certes toujours bien pour les noirs mais
pas si simple exact un truc c'est que si
tu fais du cahier j'essaie tout cas la
tour après elle rentre là bas tu sais
pas ce qui se passait oui mais c'est ce
qu'il est en train de s'esquisser en
train de voir en même temps c'est son
problème pas le nôtre donc mais c'est
vrai que quand tu prends le fera après
tu pousses les petites questions à puce
et ouais c'est facile à jouer la f3 non
il ya déjà 3 pour enfin il ya les tours
entre les cependant alors attends est ce
que ça tient ça il met le roi des 4 es
obligé de mettre de rouen des quatre
peut-être 1,3 c 5 avec l'idée de faire
des catéchètes sacrifier mpaa caps add
on à 4 c'était beau la seule chance 3,3
hors des cas et après tu vois un endroit
c'est un héros c'est un mais attend les
pions l'argent tu peux ah non ça va être
nul je suis pas sûre laurent je suis pas
sur ce que quand tu fais f4 f5 fccf
frissons à tort à l'image des chances il
est plus de temps gamal malgré son
pendant flamand facile à dire et ouest
est une car aucun intéressante soit
encore la caméra quand il fait des
choses intéressantes il est bon il était
bon c'est parti là c'est une rave party
c'est ouais c'est une bonne partie est
ce que little joe
l'iedom les conseils pendant le entre
les rondes entre eux iront je pense pas
qu'ils puissent par contre à l'heure et
demie de pause je pense qu'un immeuble à
l as interdirait à l'accord c'est
interdit mais je crois que pendant la
pause ils ont le droit d'accord donc fou
c4 dont qui chargent du fiasco du fiasco
de la partie d'avant partie d'avant son
camaïeu de machin s'était vu sa cavale
et o2 en ayant ces pièces sont ressortis
rio
cabello 2 il va jamais prendre le 2
maxime ça existe deux façons ils contre
attaquent le cadre donc sarah voilà il
prend pas eu de parce que si l'ue s'y
reprend à deux on est moins bien sûr
dont la foux 17 il laisse plus ou moins
deux baies 5 pour ses vidéos a annoncé
le pion à m'énerver redon sur camélia
des quatre ans prises elle protège
ils protègent ils ne créent pas de
menace mais il protège mais il peine à
céret et prades fera marche pas et qui
est précieux non plus tomber assez
bizarre non
on demande long qui est le second dans
de maxime est ce que c est ce que tu
peux lâcher cette info je peux lâcher ça
faut donc je sais que métier de
maquereaux travail souvent accusée ce
n'est pas tout c'était un secret donc
voilà au moins etienne et je crois pour
les gros tournois après il a d'autres
d'autres z
je sais pas exactement et en plus j'ai
pas trop envie de savoir parce que moi
je suis un peu comme ça et pour manu
c'est qu'ils auraient comme manu soit le
moins tu en sais le mieux ses choix
ouais c'est mieux parce que tu vois moi
je suis franchement je m'entends très
bien c'est mon ami maxime donc j'ai pas
envie d'avoir des infos tu vois que je
devrais pas avoir s'ils n'étaient pas
amis tu vois rien je comprends on est tu
vois pas ce que moi il faut que je sois
je peux pas dire à magnus écoute pour
cette partie ste foy parfois c'est comme
ça vous préparez donc j'ai pas envie
d'avoir des infos que de toute façon je
n'utiliserai pas mais en fait tu vois ça
me fait un nom
non mais c'est sûr j'ai envie moi j'en
sais un l'étude mais tu te portes et
c'est vrai pour à peu près tout
d'ailleurs sa pensée en fait c'était
parti non mais là dans ce cas là c'est
un peu spécial toit du coup est ce qu'on
va faire du dam de tours fc un côté
hikaru et qui est mieux d autonomie même
si je préfère toujours les blancs ses
positions là mais je les joue mal donc
ça sert à rien de
d'avoir mon avis qui n'a aucune valeur
mais gérer les blancs aux dames au dos
dames w4 taux resteront tourbe et c'est
un vrai fossé de sa fête faut essayer
d'avancer cette majorité aigle et blanc
style d'affaires à 4 5 des 6 évidemment
des avancées chaque jour d'un cran très
bien après à quel point tu y arrives à
quel point les noix arrive à avancer
leurs pions m dames s'appellera évident
tu vois aller finale par contre je pense
que sont patrick pour les as tu recules
mais bon la dame elle va ou une fois
qu'elle a lancé un aéro bondit ou
peut-être qu'il veut changer une à aa la
tactique à vous prend il ya quatre mois
lors à tence pas fini encore c'est pas
fini mais c'est pas très bien engagée
ouais c'est vrai que tu peu pareil tu
peux pas prendre un tu peux pas te
verrais pas protégés non c'est la merde
là c'était bien joué en dame souffrant
v5
ah ouais vas voir le truc très de
balayeur à ménaka il est fort là ils
étaient obligés de la finale du coton bt
une idée tu vois c'est à la tactique aux
services stratégiques tu vois pas ce
qu'ils n'avaient pas de casse de repli
pour protéger son pion b5 donc c'est en
fait c'est ils le forcent échanger et
dames et c'est un bon deal pour lui tant
n'a qu'a fait la gueule on unis seraient
qui fait la gueule at once et 8 ha oui
et maintenant il ya plus de je pense
qu'il est tout reprendre et 5 tout à
l'heure mais en fait on prend c'est un
maintenant à la tour eiffel les plus
belles et plus protégés avant ils
situent fait d'amener ce tour c'est 5
c'est ça les regarde regarde regarde
regarde mais ces acteurs ciudad cas
c'est fantastique
non mais la vidéo de naka c'est juste
c'est juste formidable tu trouves
l'arrière-garde regarde ça c'est c'est
incroyable c'est un spectacle à lui est
insupportable nous convient bien sûr
un live c'est pas ça fait pas mal rires
quoi donc de nom surtout quand fait des
grimaces et parce que là pour le
globalement et l'entraînement
qu'est-ce qui fait sur 17 lancers 7 il
faut être quatre bon il fait d'abord ça
et 17h non mais ses marques au showcase
à ce jour mais pas tant que ça
maxime l'air bien concentrés en tout cas
il ya 3 2 qui arrive
il aime bien ces trucs là maxime sait où
il s'en sort faut être quatre il fait
tout reprendre cet hilarant à la qualité
allez vous être quatre tours b prend 17
et puis après tout qu'un tas de est vrai
talent fou g7 qui va te soutenir ses
champs oui je vois un peu le chat un
sport sans son plafond qu'ils n'ont
pourtant pas vu ici va bientôt faire le
chat quoi hein
est ce que moi je fais le chat parfois
dans le stream d'accord après tout il
faut être un femme voilà souvent fait
pour ça
bref je suis souvent sous des deux s'est
terminée juste d'apprendre et de nom et
faux pas ce qu'il veut mais bon on a eu
beaucoup de surprises dans cette partie
vous avez tant qu'on y est sam ses
limites quand même oui il a abandonné
dommage c'est quoi le score à 3-2 n'a
qu'à hawaï 7/4 au canal ayant un ça va
et là tu as vu paulina il repart de
l'autre côté il repart tu vois gens
j'étais en retard je te jure karo kann
je rêve ans ce jeune italienne a déjà ce
qui me ce qui me plaît dans ce match
c'est que on voit qu'ils les deux jours
le prenne vraiment au sérieux
ouais ouais parce qu'on a eus vue des
matches de ce pitch as laurent août à 20
joueurs enfin jean hmam et par exemple
il se retrouve à jouer à trois ou à je
crois au premier coup un moment donné
c'était non mais j'aime bien ce truc là
ils sont bons si au moins ces trucs là
et c'est vrai que ma mais mam et en bits
il est bizarre parce qu'il ya des jours
où il joue vraiment très bien il ya des
jours où j'étais surpris pendant les
grands prix les grandes gestour
kambly 200 rapide il soit pas plus plus
fort que jamais ah ouais mais il n ya
pas d très bons réflexes
ça joue quand même c'est une excellente
initiative soit mais il est je crois pas
qu'il y ait des très bons réflexes des
positions simple qui voit il n'est pas
il est pas très sûr de moi il me
surprend pas mais vraiment pas comment
il joue très très bien mais il joue et
je veux pas c'est bien de ça et qu'il
calculait très très bien c'était
vraiment très impressionnant à voir
il est étudié il trouver très vite il
est numéro deux par jour
wen mais avec pas loin enlevé sa fille
d'amis n'est pas bon contre manu s'il
cherchait à gagner aussi manu et c'est
spécial c'est à bienne il avait un point
de retard et il cherchait vraiment et tu
voyages après elle provoque et donc
c'est sa première victoire en partie
longue
ouais c'est sa première victoire contre
magnus alors qu'il a perdu il a perdu
cinq ou six facile donc mais quand même
mais quand même il a fait le mode
portières et le petit ding tu en penses
quoi
ding je pense qu'il est extradé un fait
ordinaire
sinon j'adore d'abord dit non je suis
jean pull et un peu côtoyé vu qu'il a vu
qu ivan reitman in us ou 5 jours il est
venu dans un stage 10 jours au qatar et
au bout de trois jours et il m'a demandé
pourquoi je aussi passivement c'est très
exactement il y avait aucune méchanceté
aucune moquerie tu vois oui 606 nu et en
analyser les positions il avancé il
avance il avancé nous avons le type il
avance il avance voiture recule pas tu
vois c'est juste qu'ils regardent avoir
une pourquoi tu es aussi facilement et
donc savez j'avais exprès derrière moi
je trouvais ça dit elle
tu vois c'était dix huit à neuf avant
qu'il me pose une question assez bon
quoi je fais ce que je peux tu vois
enfin pourquoi tu es aussi du leur en ai
donc dit qu'il avait beaucoup d'idées
très créatif très intéressant et qui
était bizarre c'est qu'il n'était pas du
tout équipés
informatiquement il hérite ex c'était
très bizarre marrant il connaissait pas
les [ __ ] tu vois il avait à peine et
wick enfin tu vois il avait vraiment il
est il avait son truc son petit son
petit portable on a demandé si elle être
un an tandis l'avait pas étrange doit y
était déjà numéro 6 ou 7 mondial oui et
puis en plus tard les chinois derrière
tu dis qu'ils ont des moyens là un truc
de fou est en fête et le belge joueur
qui va se préparer pour ces interclubs
de n2 enfin juste pas plus mais très
créative très intéressant enfin vraiment
vraiment très bon et gentil comme make a
wave dans un chantier
si on l'a blessé en fait il a été il
collait pas été blessé le premier jour
au foot
ces problèmes quand tu joues avec
norvégien pour la première fois quoi
t'es pas pu toucher pour maîtriser un
minimum que tu te fais pousser doivent
globalement et donc ça joue un petit peu
de jeu c'est faut fouiller les voitures
une fois le contact sinon c'est un peu
comme la première league au foot mais
ils sont light
oui c'est ça c'est un peu surprenant
dépeint mémoire des victimes
ouais ça se passe pas très bien de
nouveau ça se passe pas mal non plus
mais c'est pas bien mais je vais trop de
fautes c'est pas mal ça ouais donc ça se
passe comment ça se passait à peu près
égale non non je pense mais ce projet on
a les blancs ça se passe pas forcément
ouais pas terrible un matériel illégal
pâte et non pas terrible du tout non
mais je commence à être inquiet alors
ans dormait là elle va se terminer par
nul cette partie mais mais globalement
je dire sur le match soit à petit et
inquiet déjà avant que ça commence mal
mais je suis plus en plus angoissés team
nuls et ouais on n'en parle plus j'ai
l'habitude d'avoir laurent tekki laurent
- fabien fait ça y est je mens je suis
pas d'accord du laurens et fille j'ai vu
d'avoir fabien qui
qui me rassure pas tout le temps ouais
d'accord doit être assuré fabien fabien
il est toujours tranquille c'est chou
ses doigts qui a pas de me dire que
comme moi il est injouable en bullet
abso fort magnus j'avais vu quelques les
deux matches d'un quart des parents
puissent ils envoient le plus on sait
tous ce n'est pas ça et j'en ai marre
avant damart 2 bat de donald k way of
life est infernal donc là maximy
calcule-t-on 36 ses trois tours c6 je
suppose sa paire marché du tout moi joe
raedle bouge pas même ses 3,6 jabour
conseils donnés nulle part attend quoi
ça marcherait pas retourner si ces trois
tours 6
je prends et je joue ces deux hoquets et
surtout ces trois dames bien comprend le
cas je pense ou des blessés comme daan
berri était trois fois
bref un tour prend le calme et 4 pas que
je voulais rex à ces cinq lots les
débats têtu fait nul mais même pas je
pense pas écouter ce qui se passe donc
c'est un peu inquiétant sur ces deux on
a raté quoi je sais pas ce qu un thé je
vois pas tant ses trois salles kounen
qui est supérieur d'autres jeux débat
pour prendre quatre à pas le temps de
faire c'est sa sixième tour dmp a été
pas mal aussi des mots bien il fait quoi
de meilleur iphone pourtant le 400 euros
plus fort non mais là c'est justin gage
qui a fait passer la partie en fait la
partie des biens abandonnés par les
photos points 4 mais non là c'est pas
tendre ouais bon madame b 1-1 c'est
bizarre c'est bizarre comme dante et je
veux aussi ça mais ça commence à faire
lourd la grand ouais on n'a qu'à y prend
son temps bon en mode et on prend le cas
de guillaume d'ambea adam et rafa 4 ha
ok on n'avait pas tous les mêmes têtes
se faire dame d un iphone md
mesdames un ton prend 1,4 et doit pas
répéter de faire tourner ses cinq ans il
a raté d'am dam dam f1 quand même mais
c'est pas des limaces la fouine
profitons prendre 1 4 elle a dû penser
comme nous il a dû rater dame f1 fait
normalement ils devraient pas penser
comme non non non j'aimerais peut-être
on est très très fort et qu'en fait on
ne le sait pas et tu vas enfin on fait
peur à tout le monde c'est pas pour rien
qu'on n'a pas été sélectionné pour le
speech à saint laurent
c'est un peu ça on était des
épouvantails l'opep et l'aïe américain
mais on a raté un truc sur trois casses
pas possible non mais c'était faux là on
n'a pas vu quelque chose le chat et des
nounous et lord il était organisé au blé
et la garde va pas du tout ce qui
pouvait à thème des deux dames des deux
oies dam des deux mais je vois je vois
d'un des deux et si je fais un échec et
que je passe derrière tu fais ces 7es à
rien ouais même jeté dame prend ces deux
à one ok donc tu vois il s'est arrêté
at-on probasis on a compris comment il
allait s'arrêter on a vu la variante
mais pas jusqu'au bout passée la
différence a heureusement pour eux
langlois il répète et 200 volontaires
j'aime pas trop cette position ok ok sûr
que sceptique sur le choix de dd des
blancs ici f4 voilà ce que je disais
tout à l'heure s'il arrive à faire le
cinq des six et au revoir parce que le
foot recasement sera sera complètement
hors jeu évident et je vois pas content
tu empêches a déjà fait pas mal maxime
qui essayent son truc
adam les six pas mal parce que empêche
5me nasa et menace d'un prime 4 sur tout
ce que je vais faire dame b3g large
s'attaque cette attaque b5 et jma ce 5
mai 4 évidemment c'est pas bon il faut
absolument évidemment faut absolument
protéger ce pur f4 avec les blancs ce
qui la fait d'amener au tour ces trois
les maximinois cette position c'est
peut-être le meilleur joueur du monde
ouais ouais c'est très dynamique au coup
par coup tu vois où il était mené
c'est assez tactique mais en même temps
il ya quand même des enjeux stratégiques
et là il peut être très fort
effectivement d'un autre côté avec les
quarts où il a aussi trouvé à qui parler
oui eh bien cette fois f5 et a vu
surtout repenser trois purs comprend
dame projet fou c'est si je pense que tu
lui de se déterminer
thomas schaaf aux citoyens non il
faudrait 5 c'est mon bien fait c'est de
la merde il a pas vu ça à mon avis
dallas comme moi surtout repenser trois
avions processus je peux faire ah ok
c'est pas fini parce que tu vois j'ai
appelé ans - dramé furent des cas très
faible et on fout g7 évidemment et comme
on disait
mais bon au moins ils appellent plus
précis il a perdu pirlo
disons que maintenant les blancs il joue
au maximum pour égaliser
il est noir parfois tu vas être moins
bien non j'ai repris oui non ouais
surtout après tour s'est vite tu veux tu
être glissé du fou g4 si on donnait
d'ailleurs être sympa ça et on préfère
un petit chat fou j'ai quatre fois au 6
allée sans reprendre de l'autre côté as
à faire l'autre diagonale en fait pour
être honnête tu préfère aller de ce côté
ouais mais bon si après que mentalist
deux options
bref un comité des fêtes du coup on part
ann mary va prendre des quatre noms mais
là ils jouent pour charger une voiture a
déjà je te prends tout en c1 et je te
fais dame prend 1,2 et c'est clair tu as
souffert ce qui fait faut pas laisser
traîner
attention il prend les pions ou des
trois peut-être rio furent des trois
espèces est pas mal hein tu mets une
fois f5 après tuit-tuit bouchain fois
fuite c'est malin ouais vous mal placé
il serait par là il couvrira les échecs
en k2 dames celui peut-être un jour on
sait pas
ils donnent pas en fait d'après eux il
doit aider 4 et va peut-être dans
l'espion sept-îles et potsdam c'est cet
add-on septime par ce qui fâche cinq là
pour un leurre h4 trop bizarre h4 ont
envie d'utiliser ce tempo pour pousser
moi j'ai pas chez tellement envie de
pousser ses pions pour pousser au rythme
du jazz
toutefois ce furent poussés 500 f 5 mm
et j'ai pensé il faut pousser les pions
toujours comme ça ben tiens pas ces
effets pourraient être poussées 1 et oui
non peut le pousser fruits de ces
merveilles ouais mais c'est pas mal ce
qu'il faut c'est à foix et boussens qui
a plombé 50 mm et jouets des trois
parfois f5 faut prouver 5 détroit il a
joué deux fois que ça ouais ouais c'est
ça des trois essais terminés tant que
l'échiquier reste vert comme ça en fait
est que la couleur change pas du tout
c'est glacé sélection geste posé la
question cinq enfants
non mais comme dit jean cela pose aussi
tu vas j'en profite pour faire une
réponse globale
ouais donc la garderie sont plus grands
que les dommages beaucoup mieux pour et
noir mais ce qu'on veut faire à 5 pour
le foot et 4 trop tard sans plus être
unis n'auraient pu mater je veux faire
dame des quatre riches ouais je pense
qu'il faut quand même des cartes déjà
pour voir où tu vas tu vas bref trois
pas l'air trop possible à cause de jouer
4 ou poseurs d'amener quatre appelés rue
je le range étroit tarifs shelton et
d'en [ __ ] casse blanche service d'avis
sur cazaux noir rassure william german
ouais non ça c'est clair bref c'est un
peu trop passif ou la dame aurait le
droit c'est bizarre échecs et des deux
là n'ont enfin l'idée de et tu pousses
en face aux clients pour moi ce pion
j'ai l'impression que plus le pion
avance laurent plus c'est dangereux
c'est l'une des plus calmes face aux
dames là quand même fou deux dames s'ils
en ont oublié nos médailles aux trois
c'est juste c'est délirant dans le foin
d'amsterdam
tu vas me le dire donc belle belle
victoire de maxime donc sur sa green fee
lièvremont mais pourquoi abandonner la
green fun menaces ou g4 aussi d'ailleurs
dans les dents les menaces voilées non
menaces tout il ya même pas un échec car
il va menacer un échec mais c'est tout
vas-y que je prends le pur d'abord ça se
dit coup droit 3 tu t'es pour se moquer
de lui peut jouer droit g7
surtout les cats et dalmat 8 mai aura g7
miroir des êtres tout de suite après
contre la caf au patron s'amuser non
plus laurent je sais jamais ce qu'il a
pu préparer
ouais mais en huit thèmes des vitrages
cette non évidemment jamais rien ici et
jamais perpète ici bah écoute
égalisation c'est important laurent la
de recoller peut pas ne pas être en
retard avant le avant les paul est mort
il faut pas il faut pas lui laisser le
truc c'est que si tu laisses du terrain
après il va construire son match de suez
car ou est tu vois c'est ce que je peux
dire qu'elle y fait de calme de beaucoup
plus est reparti avec les noirs et les
blancs à vue des deux jeunes femmes là
qu'il a gagné la première ou l'autre se
retrouvent elles seront 1,3 et celle là
là était assez joli avec les blancs
c'était moins tu vois c'est l'italienne
solide voulu essayer d'en gagner
allez si l'on gagne une sur trois est
ici bien mais c'est une nouveau ce qu'on
a un an et c'est la même et tu sens tu
vois tu le sens pas prêt c'est du tout
en fait non il va changer là franchement
c'est pas un tel cocktail qu'hergé si
c'est ce que je voulais dire tout à
l'heure mais on passe à autre chose
le cayor g6 et un peu mal placé il ya
peu il ya juste pas assez de pièces ici
on en met de la pression l'adamant betis
est bien placé et à tokyo en métro qui
est faible et vous qu'à l'ouverture il
pourrait jouer un maximum avec les
blancs qui correspondrait vraiment à son
style et sur l'a45 c'est compliqué
durin très dur taris qui peut switcher
sur les anglaises par exemple mais ça
s'est mal passé quand 49 je me rappelle
les cds anglaise mais ça se passe pas
très bien faut être voulez sentir non
après tu as le droit de l'as et
italiennes assez bizarre de répéter à
chaque fois la position il ya plus de
pièces sur votre casque ou tu vois la
camorra il adore ça c'est la même
c'est exactement la même là non là il a
plus rien c'est sûr et lucas il prend
1,5 c'est je crois que c'est exactement
la même qu'il ya deux parties d'un oui
mais juste les noirs sont hyper
confortable je préfère même jeu avec les
noirs ici alors en bon si je pense qu'il
ya rien objectivement mais j'ai perdu
parce que c'est plus facile de bouger
les pièces d'un et monsieur bah y'a
jamais rien dans ce sens dans ce truc
que je disais hier la partie comme
cramique j'ai l'impression qu'il ya eu
tu vois qui s'est passé cinquante mille
trucs et rebelle d'ordi moustapha il met
00 sauf un moment quand didot de pioche
à 0,70 ça bouge jamais tu vois je n'aime
pas trop les tours comme ça après c'est
pas mauvais mais j'ai l'impression
qu'avec les plantes est plus proche de
faire une connerie
bien sûr bien sûr non c'est pas facile
je sais pas plus facile à jouer c'est
aussi ça le but de l'italienne tu vois
c'est que c'est plus facile à jouer pour
les blancs drame et là on voit ça y est
c'est là il a déjà des préavis des
quatre mêmes là qui peut arriver il ya
un mode là déjà il est dans votre
défense
ouais soit c'est en joue depuis deux
minutes si la bible en charge je pense
que c'était la dernière
en tout cas c'est la dernière exactement
comme ça qu'on voyait et price n'est pas
un petit peu à l'écossaise laurent
maxime cela pourrait du coup on encaisse
le problème c'est que ça marche plus du
tout analysé l'écossaise c'était une
torture l'aigle et blanc parce que tout
le monde a essayé de faire en fait parce
que les gens peut-être ne réalise pas et
c'est que tous les genres du top niveau
et essayer de faire marcher écossaise et
personne n'a réussi parce que et c'est
en fait personne ne la jouent donc
personne ne comprend 10 un truc oublié
mais en fait pas du tout tous vont
essayer de faire marcher écossaise
compris et compris nous-mêmes maxima
dernière français quand on a joué le
match contre karekin donc qui nous aider
et on a passé pas mal de temps sur
écossaise déjà côté noir
et puis côté blanc aussi éventuellement
et ça ne marche pas du tout c'est
terrible c'est dommage mais
elle a mis 6 pour l'instant en tout cas
d'aline kovalev cinéma voilà c'est pour
ça que n'a qu'à moi il essayait h4 sa
main ces dames ou 2007 et il a écrit un
coup de hache 4 a jeté l'écosystème mon
répertoire donc je connais un petit peu
et du coup je vais bien placé
la russie bien placé pour savoir que ça
marche par en fait ouais
l'écossaise ans clint caisse non mais
l'écossaise après pour les gens qui sont
dans le chat ou quoi évidemment laurent
il parle il parle de son niveau
stratosphérique meta même des mecs comme
roublev ski tout ça qu'il a joué ça va
au qui la joue même plus un oui enfin
qu'il aille jouer mais jacques à 2000
jusqu'à 2003 2004 ça va ouais oui bien
sûr je prends ça regarde moi je vous
même la scandinave
franchement non mais la scandinave c'est
vraiment pour y continuer à ce qu'en dit
nabeul écossaise c'est une bonne
ouverture en gros même norme et non les
blancs sont vos moyens mais c'est très
fort s'est remplie c'est ça le problème
c'est pas que taper une disposition
légale
en fait c'est que ça fait nul quoi c'est
c'est compliqué même tom ac a battu cram
nico aime bien sûr écossaise mais tu
auras la position après douze coups il
était à -1 5 ans va mais j'étais mal
mais j'étais mal mais il a gagné des
poules à jouer mais tu vois il a arrêté
la super génial qui vous va pas et
justement contre contre étienne gaillat
jouer quelque 3,3 alors que les tiers
d'êta joueurs de 4,5 et on en parlait un
peu la veille justement l'écossais
s'était assez peu probable qu'ils la
fassent ya deux choix et petite idée il
ya une belle partie comptant match qui
n'en gagner oui oui ça ouais en fait oui
encore neuf à six mois je pense pas à
comprendre cela et je sais pas si c'est
parce que il n'est jamais répéter donc
pour le mans en fait pas trop d'idées
non mais c'est vrai que les structures
je suis donc à en croire cette zone fait
rare c'est intéressant soit des 8-10
dont trois des huit
olala vous prends mes cinq détroit et
new line au gatt tour des huit à tempo
attention ça rigole pas
et non seulement je sais pas jouer la
pièce et je gagne la dame puisque sur
bf2 la foulée 4 bref il apparaît une
entrée dans mail aston reprend dessin le
centre est faible en fait c'est ça le
problème de heal six f4 il faut que
j'arrive à faire aux cinq des six dans
sa fin il va t'il perd une nouvelle
bonne fête en fait il n'a trouvé 100 is
fine italienne il fait du genre de
minutes
et puis gagner que la colère du fénoir
voilà il joue avec les noirs c'est sa
stratégie
ça serait drôle tu sais qui six organes
celle là qui fasse la même partie des
italiennes pour faire vite
et qu'est ce que n'a qu'à pourrait faire
pour pour pour se sortir de ce problème
jack russel y jouer trois premiers mais
ça peut tu penses et l'asie
et pas qu'à moi je vais au 4 mars
voilà donc le ceva la voile et roya
dessins que c'est ça le problème
ben tu te faire des 4 attend plus
alors ça donne quoi il a joué dame f3 ou
à f/5 n'est pas bête hein c'est
stratégiquement c'est un peu bizarre
parce que tu donnes les cases noires
mais tu veux jouer pour f6 pour pure est
toujours bas tout simplement
ouais et maxime qui est de changer les
pièces à feu doux et matt est quand même
dans ce genre de truc hein attention le
retour de bâton est très cher ta
potentiellement 1 fois 5 qui est amour
sans toi et je te tue permettra qu'une
d'amendés 6 ou inversement et à deux
blocs
ouais ça a l'air d'être compliqué pour
pour hikaru mais bon est-ce qu'en même
temps je vois pas en fait le temps tu
veux il reste 27 minutes
une reste 27 minutes de cette cadence
après une heure de trois minutes après
le bullet mais le but n'est de toute
façon ce sera le feu laurent ouais je
regarde géographe jamais un tir après
faut des grosses affiches pour regarder
en entier mais le match vraiment qui
était magnifique c'était
c'était gris tchouda je pense sur les 20
premières parties n'a pas eu une nulle
ouais d'accord incroyable s'il a battu
finalement s'il a battu 15 hacking est
chaud à metz pas c'est pas donné à tout
le monde tu vois regarde moi qui aie
qu'elle est dans les rues des six obligé
obligés de faire quelque chose
d'artificiel b3 c2 qui arrivait un adams
et 4 dames hausse est très bien joué
très bien joué dès fois il va gagner
encore non tu protèges comment 3,3 wells
3 seul coup ouais enfin c'est pas très
bien quand même tu fais la gueule et les
du vaste wafers et d'apprendre et 4 donc
on met quatre vingts matin avec les
noirs on peut pas j'en sais rien c'était
compliqué après c'est de faire un roi g7
f600 c'est d'essayer de turin de
multiplier les idées à avoir laissé du
bien aux rois g7 est ce que je suis fier
de tout reprendre et 4 mais roger c'est
que j'ai mené ce qu on nomme 34,8 orages
seront en fait il revenait juste avec la
dame je crois waouh ça c'est un contre
les menaces d'un point f7 quand même un
oui si je fais tout ressources est mon
rôle est bien joué et il menace d'un
rachat maintenant elle sait jamais
peut-être qui menace d'un match énorme
il est gagnant mais j'espère bien alors
ans j'espère bien mais alors il à machin
mais si l'autre surtout reprend b4
est-ce que sur d'un machin sera pas roi
f2 ou alors fait d'accord pour le moral
car on marque il n'y aurait il est
peut-être pas trop le choix en fait non
il veut faire il le fait mais ça
s'appelle matière pour détourner la
timeline et à se tourner en arrière
matin et regain assayas et rigole pas
bijoux 8,6 à faire dameuse pour essayer
de couvrir il faut pas il peut pas
isoler des positions comme ça dacca -
oui ou hackers purement saura garder
pour vous entendre
le conseil le conseil de certains
écoutent bien droit tout ça dans
l'iphone qui est là qui se bat contre
une dame une faute
la dame fall à tour tu vois avant ok il
prend des plus grandes et on sait
comment ça se termine et que tu vois ça
se termine par un coup de faux seins ou
d'amour 35 heures autour des 1 et
maintenant deux elfes ou des deux
matches joli à demain matin + copie
d'accords et ses attentes ' selon les
goûts il convient pas à bord serait la
cata on l'a vu arriver qu'elle va cette
hausse donc c'est vrai on a encore une
italienne avait des coups à gauche et
sirops fait la même c'est mon héros
c'est fantastique si on fait exactement
la même tir fillon victoire à m c'était
à l'autriche a rejeté à 6 ok tu
t'adresses qui il avait absolument aucun
problème c'est juste pour voir un peu
dans le chatt 1 h fest qui dit qu'il
avait reçu le même conseil que naka pour
ses prix régional d'alerté des
changements sont 20 h trois fois c'était
une déposition principal de la ligne et
bd de hockey faut 6 ça c'est comme
chronique
ok juste bref je tout échangés s'est
élevé dé 5 ha ok vous cette position ok
avec ça c'est très compliqué à évaluer
mais faut qu'il fasse cavalier afin
hawkeye ses quatre fautes 3 tu vois
quelque chose comme ça ils essaient dé
changer le faut parce que ça peut être
dangereux l'attaquant a du coup la torah
devient un peu colmater ou sinon ouais
moi j'ai plus tous les prêts si j'aime
pas trop ces structures avec les blancs
vraiment arrêter pas fan non pas sur les
nombreux problèmes mais je vois ces
actifs quand même c'est pas facile a en
plus avec un linge ou h3 tu vois c'est
embêtant
toi le pack d'avants joue h3 ici et gris
blanc sait que claire lecavalier 24 ce
qui va arriver rapidement tu peux pas
faire g37 souvent talent et g3 tu vois
pour virer un cavalier fait qu'elle soit
échec trois jets d'eau et c'est pas
grave tu vois il doit
doit bouger quand même mais je vous il
le fait en a peut-être du fait recaler
leurs cadres du coup pour empêcher ce
couple et trois sacs et voilà les bleus
sont bien loin ce qui va réussir à
pousser des quatre communes ok il est
assez mal joué au lieu de je sais pas
pourquoi fait il se croit au but là
parce que il a joué veulent coup en 30
secondes notamment
il n'y a pas là y'a pas le feu là
pourquoi j'ai aussi fitch force voilà
les bords sont très mal pas tu vois ta
j'avais déjà jamais eu de cas où tu
crées une menace à l'endroit ait eu hâte
c'est celle qui est faible s'ils
viennent de cauchemar après il faut
juste protéger ou 4 faire attention car
j'ai six a aucune perspective est
toujours dominé dans ces structures n ya
pas trop de casse pour rebondir à oued
en âge suite peut-être h8 france seniors
vers la fuite dès cette c5 mais ça
parait dur
ouais ouais ça peut être un truc
s'exécute pas 117 tu te tapes ion talent
fiancée 7 qui saute
malgré cette crise menace quand même
ouais j'ai deux trois sets ok il se bat
même comme dame
on n'est pas surpris parfois alors une
question intéressante dans le chat est
ce que tu penses comme la ddt que
l'avenir des échecs passe par le 960
question qui revient souvent en fait
c'est pour ça que je l'aï trop long
terme je sais pas là pour l'instant ça
va encore non à cause des prépas pour
raismes et moi ça m'arrive tu vois tu es
en train de te vois tu veux mon job est
en train de me de deux mètres à pôle
emploi est hors de question je réponds
oui
non mais c'est un hasard puisque de
toute façon ça n'aura aucune influence
je pense pas pour l'instant il ya une
position qui sont bizarre aussi aux 260
qui n'ont pas trop de sens c'est ce
qu'elles sont plus intéressants je sais
pas mais c'est que c'était marrant
regarder ce truc à senlecques soit géré
mais je trouve ça pas mal donc peut-être
non mais c'est un débat qui revient
chacun a son avis
moi je pense que l'échec est pas morte
tu vois non moi je pense que ça pourrait
devenir un mix quoi le truc degré de
chou que tu vois qu'ils disaient tu vois
il ya deux candidats il faisait nul avec
les blancs parce qu'on peut rien faire
on doit chroniquer un perdu des partis
et des noirs oui oui encore complètement
mort d'après savais qu'avec les
ordinateurs et tout ça ça devient le
plus compliqué moi je voulais faire les
échecs 12 fin que j'appelais chez sky en
fait
mais bah en fait l'idée c'est que le 960
trouve que le problème c'est que
personne s'y retrouvent parce que les
tourelles sont n'importe où avec le roi
pour opel et donc moi je propose est de
faire les échecs douce eu plein de
positions mais en fait c'était de
laisser les tours est le roi sur les
mêmes case de départ de simplement
bouger les autres pièces en fait parce
que bâle eiger si on n'a que dix
positions ça suffit au site loi n'a pas
forcément d'avoir enfin déjà d'animal à
préparer quand il ya quand même une
position quand même pour se rappeler
tout donc si tu en as dit oui il y aura
beaucoup moins de poids pas vraiment
préparé donc voilà un peu moi je devrais
je sais cette idée là tu vois pour
bourges pour changer sans tout
chambouler non plus quoi un truc un peu
intermédiaire écoute ouais je sais pas
et coûteux aussi il atteint 103 c'est
vrai qu'on est habitués mais c'est
surtout pour le top niveau non je pense
pas que la position de départ elle pose
un problème au niveau amateur tu vois
non non c'est pour ces pour le top
niveau et n'a qu'à il s'en sort la haye
contre attaque mais il a réussi à il est
pas réussi à percer 26 même s'il faut
pas qu'elles pouvaient y avait des
champions première du tf cartes et
chèques ouais ouais et valeur du moderne
mais ce qui paraît mieux un arrêt clé
noir mais ça dépend ça dépend juste un
cahier faux savants cool ce qu'on peut
tenter pions prend la semoy qui bouge
les pièces qui avait lieu 3 et tf 4 ne
marche pas alors je comprends bien qu'il
tienne l'homme cirque alliage deux ans
sur l'un j'ai peur qu'elle trois
lecteurs de avaient fait quatre heures
surtout on prend cavaliers ou trois je
vais peut-être à nantua
j'ai bêtement et de penser cette hausse
était chômée a fait qu'il a fait il a
fallu attendre j'ai rejoint ge qui par
inadvertance lafarge capion prend ouais
tiens tu es un yves repartir par là bas
ou déjà fait savoir que ce que tu disais
tout à l'heure
1 il y aura c'est cette emprise bien
exact donc ils vont partir par là mais
il est dans son bunker mais c'est
dommage ça assez chaud pourquoi la zdf
que voyage 2 à oui non c'est le chat
alors attend peut-être qu'il ya le
chrono mais je pense que les vingt-sept
minutes sont sont tombés qu'il ya plus
de temps où j'ai parié il ya une en un
problème de chronomètre laurent taille
et 20h15 donc à rien une erreur de
chronomètre du couche dans le méli
d'accord très bien j'ai vu une question
là sur lautier kg j'avais été 2007 en
fait il a été il a été 15e joueur
mondial
donc ce qui est mieux que 2007
maintenant quoi donc il y avait une
relation je pense qu'il avait été tué au
même niveau ou la personne au même
niveau à 10 ans plus tard il aurait 2007
sans problème alors je vais pas le
niveau mais à l'époque où il était
vraiment dans les meilleurs il y avait
cette fille joueurs 2007 et maintenant
maintenant quand on regarde duchess 2007
sanchez 6-1 combien 50 60
même moi quand je l'étais à pomoy y
avait 45 40 45 au départ et après ben
ali à 55,60 je pense déjà à 2,4 en
juillet 2000 voilà c'est sa 10e mondial
et de 1702 voilà c'est ça et l'inflation
ça avait une autre wallemme l'époque où
il était il était à son top après les
débuts de les années 2000
là il a arrêté tout d'un coup un il
arrêtait tout d'un coup il avait perdu
le la times time que je pense d'eux mais
vous êtes champion du monde c'est décidé
c'est ce qu'ils disaient alors est ce
qu'il disait quand il était gamin tu
vois encore 20,4 il était jeune pas ses
interviews je pense que c'était pas
c'était vrai que jamais la reine et que
c'était complètement pas possible et
qu'il allait prendre du plaisir s'il
prend plus de plaisir ça s'arrête quand
moi j'aime bien cela j'aime bien jouer
donc ça va encore temps c'est donc
j'apprécie je joue mais tu joues bien
aussi c'est agréable
enfin je pense que je veux bien encore
en faillite joue à 26,50 la pareille non
non il jouait bien mais non juifs pour
être bues voie pour maintenir parce
qu'il était dos heures et était donc il
n'ya pas de problème j'apprécierais plus
jouer si j'avais ton niveau peut-être je
me disais c'est possible mais c'est plus
marrant fait quand tu vois plus de
choses ouais ouais je peux dire les
choses avec magnus en fait on est tous
on est tous le kevin de quelqu'un ce
qu'on appelle à tous ouais tous envie de
jouer mieux en fait les agglos allemand
à tous les niveaux il a fait part à le
plonger il tient complètement squeeze et
brille d'abord de hockey dommage
5 gigas mais il ya une jeune femme
derrière il faut qu'ils essaient de
faire mieux avec des melons c'est pas
possible c'est un beau match alors on
qu'à l'heure auxquelles on assiste non
c'est pas moi c'est pas mal du tout il
ya 7 seven façon très marrante wi fi co
ries a fait que c'est marrant quand même
cette histoire de rire avec les noirs
c'est vrai quand même ajouter nice des
fois quand tu regardes les mecs se
fabriquer toulon c'est chiant quand cité
pour un joueur et que célia breaks
débreaks breaks débreaks sens où
l'entend peu plus quoi ouais aph whaling
les noirs c'est vrai que blitz koenig
les noirs monde est là oui je recolle à
l'habitude
je vais maintenant vous trouviez pas b5
je crois que c'est plutôt heureusement
tabaczka kg de trois thèmes a cessé
après pas parce qu'il après mouvaux fgf
d'accord non ça ne ferait pas de cadeau
à la wii sa prépa oui toi parce qu'ils
apprennent ou veut prendre cinq ans fait
les faits qualifiés 3 et l'après
mouvement f 5 mai
et c'est chaud quand même de près
mouvement 5 plus ah ouais fois par an
non c'est ça c'est comme les astros ja a
rien de primes aux vins où la tendresse
que je peux pas prendre il faut 7
je bougeais pièce je vois ça c'est chaud
no way
tu es fou des cinq châteaux l'imam à
l'épreuve 7 minimum est ce que c'est si
grave
l'eau est ce qu'elle est c'est cette
voie et je peux te faire car elles sont
dangereuses c'est ouais ouais on va
retourner à la partie voire wesley
rockets hilare ok il est tout simplement
pas mais le prévenu reprend 1,5 à
marseille c'est spécial
p5 allait jouer mais c'est mûrement il
se remplit et découvertes
la force quand même un très bon coup et
sa fille là je ne fous jamais garde des
sceaux fierté voilà les noirs sont mieux
statut sa souplesse l affaire c'est
juste non mais n'importe quoi la wave 4
kg par an à chaud c'est génial non mais
accueille deux échecs en plus rien nada
petit avion mais inhabituelle a eu des
mois
oui bah tu as envie de dire ce cavalier
et awa ile de france
il est matérialiste ailleurs nous en 11
ans un moment pendant ce truc j'aurais
po prime s'ils ont vu voici les faire tu
prends tout comme si c'était vrai qui
prend il prend tour et il prend tout ils
échangent tout il ou elle est partie
dans le style quel massacre encore
sefouhi laissant pas du tout ses
positions notamment il déjoue mer la
faute peut-être qui change un nac ah
ouais je crois qu'à ça va pas tarder est
ce que tu es ce qu'ils ont du mal à
changer d'ouverture comme ça parce que
c'est un peu le combat de coqs tu vois
et donc là il a pour maître coq allait
mal mais bon super 12 défaites d'affilée
comme moi avec la ritaline tu vois
c'est blitz et rapide ces joueurs là
j'ai joué le championnat du monde et
championne d'europe avant l'année
dernière je perdais mais il parti après
l'autre genre populaire cij a incité un
peu quand même parce que manger beaucoup
regarder tout ça rien à faire c'est pas
facile ainsi tournois sur terre et du
monde de billes ses partisans- jeunes
traités car quand tu vas jouer à toi
comme ça est ce que tu as encore espoir
de gagner
non non non non j'ai l'espoir de faire
un top 10 ça se passe très très bien
tu dis pas sur un malentendu je suis en
grosse forme jarnac tout le monde sait
que j'avais des appareils mort je
l'avais anello vraiment préfère aller on
oblige à 2630 pense pas qu'ils reflètent
tout à fait d'ailleurs j'ai gagné
beaucoup de pauvres j'allais 2720 un peu
de temps j'ai reperdu j'ai rejoint un
tournoi tu vois j'ai fait les 40 points
ou alors c'est là où la leaf si on
commence à 8h du matin en fait c'est
bizarre ce tournoi
non c'est bien bon ils font quelque
chose toi mais tu joues 18 ronde de
qualif le samedi tu vois la terrible le
dimanche tu es enfant quoi alarmer
voulait vraiment bref ça m'a coûté 40
points l'eau et donc du coup je repars
sur j'ai vraiment des appariements web
l'un d'eux même et j'avais suivi en
direct et j'avais je suis peut-être
quelques de thé party au début oui je
jouais pas mal mais c'était bien t'es
pas bien mais je me rappelles tu te
battais on suit toujours la façon de
jouer mamediarov et népotique voit donc
que le truc c'est pas facile mais en
fait c'est on faire la fin je fais un
truc quand je suis des coupes du monde
les championnats animant les choses
comme ça en fait s'il ya etienne où toi
je vous suis au début parce que je sais
qu'on va suivre maxime après mange même
d'accord mais je sais pas dit méchamment
gravé dans la logique veut qu'on suive
maxime après donc quand vous faites un
bon tournoi c'est etienne où toi en fait
j'essaye de même si maxime est un peu
devant mais je vais vous garde à vue
qu'il pouvait faire quelque chose non
mais tu vois je me dis tant que tant que
vous n'êtes pas mal ces plaisirs station
tu regardes que maxime même temps en
temps un peu marre au programme en sapin
sur la
chrétienne et fait une belle coupe du
monde l'an dernier à oum accès et perdu
contre les bonnes c'était juste histoire
c'était en géorgie non il a perdu contre
beau deuxième tour ouais mais enfin je
sais pas c'était marrant quelques rêves
perdus au deuxième tour contre bout mais
c'était chaud est mais en fait ce qui
m'a laissé ça c'est parce que bout à
éliminer magnus derrière ça fait quand
même qu'au deuxième tour ce à raison
vraiment y avait eu leur tasse et et
faire les premiers tours et les terres
du premier tour au départage contre yb
en dessous donc pas facile et car on se
bat mais ça risque de pas être assez
vous savez tracé a pas ici de faire le
plein complet 1
une fois de plus mais je dirais que ça
va être assez mais bon mais ce que
j'arrive à 13,4 dans des bonnes
conditions
c'est ça la mais j'ai l'impression qu'il
ya recettes qui est une énorme menace
parce que une fois je les rois heureux
c'est 3 des 6 juin se déroulent ces
singes étaient beaux arts et on a une
petite halte pour repartir avec la tour
après du coup est donc faux j'arrive à
te le poème de tourcoing f4 échec se
demandent ils à tours 6 j'ai téléchargé
toi parce que le grand bain voilà je
veux juste poussé envoya ses actifs
tu peux aussi fort risqué un truc avec
des scies cessé de s'activer de f3 a eu
cette idée mais je passais vider mes
pensées qui les tours et remparts est
peut-être la meilleure chance que tanger
3.4 projet de ross
après on fait pas juste trois sets du
coup comme ça on laisse faire on va
prendre quatre projets 2 c'est la partie
d'ailleurs ça m'en aille est malin il
est malin il est malin laurent et oui
c'est pas bien c'est de faire tout bref
si ce matin ouais non mais c'est chiant
de donner des soins à fausser cagnard
prouver la page vos coudes avant que
je sais pas ce qu'il doit faire la cie
permet ça que ça va être mieux même
quand des 5,7 4,4 qui est trop faible
pas mal hein il défend bien mais il
farah tf6 peut-être alors celle qu
est-ce qu utiliser le monde on y propose
après toi aussi tu vas pas et tu vas
jamais gagné la champions reprend ses 4
tu peux pas attendre les six as et ça
c'est une avance roi des six maintenant
ça fonctionne vraiment tout reprendre et
c'est important je pense va et ça c'est
nul c'est sûr il va mettre le foin f3 et
c'est fini mais juste 3.94 d'abord là
pour commencer
d'ailleurs après quatre ateliers tour g6
avec on n'est pas d'accord et il a peu
pris parce qu'il perd des braves parce
qu'il garry ils le gardent sous pression
en fait non parce qu'il est tout petit
non mais c'est raté pas dans l'ombre
elle fait confiance
non mais parce que sur géant tour promet
cinq tours j'ai trois échecs 6 0 après
quatre shows des tours j'ai cas je
ramassais il y avait là car hélas ok il
est en confiance pour faire une danse à
ok pas si sûr ça ça doit être nul mais
le tour sur la tour b 6 par exemple
autour aussi pour faire tout autre tour
sur la troisième mais tu vas pas pouvoir
ce truc non watch 4
tu as voulu mettre en exergue c'est pas
comment on peut rentrer en fait le truc
c'est que dès qu'il irait 1re cat rouge
et quatre règles droit il va lui faire
les causes des échecs
c'est ça en fait il faut qu'il garde un
échec car j'ai six quand il vient le 1re
cat sinon c'est fini il faut qu'il ya eu
à lui dominé le fond donc il fait foulée
si direct ce qui est pas mal aussi
bref 5 menacé deux cas c'est pas mal ça
ouais mais le fouillis facture soit en
d3 la whey pour ces trois là il peut pas
faire faute et celle pascal verrot 4
brassard et on attend les parois 4 et 11
points à trois par ici 4 il avait annulé
tous les six échecs toi parce que la
finale de pions je pense que je peux la
gagner les gars culture et sur la 4e ray
ouais donc s'était tenue la chine est
pas loin quand même hein ouais bon et
tournoi parce qu'on mange pas de pain
moi j'ai 10 heures alors attendre d'eux
attend maintenant
ouais matin il veut faire bref 3 il va
faire fou fou fou bessette ici c'est
trois ou quatre à temps mais là y'a
parents h4 juste sais pas si oui ils
n'ont mais il a fait le retour des deux
fois 2ème et attend à tour des deux feux
de haies tu veux pas sacrifier
ouais mais attendent pas faire juste
orbite à tomber de b3 à je pensais
qu'elle gagner cette position en fait
non même pas arrêt donc c'est vraiment
nul
voilà c'est vrai on est là bas je
pensais que ça gagner ça non non c'est
déjà elle atteindre cette finale mais
alors il ya toujours paroisse gkp passe
cafu 17 au foot de m bien joué et un
iphone s est fait il allait rentrer là
dedans tu qu'il n'est pas trop le choix
après je sais qu'il a beaucoup étudié
vous risquez compagne et il en a parlé
plus d'une fois dans ses interviews
laurent way nakamura
ouais d'accord mais à nous imaginer
c'est ce qui lie les devrait être
quelque chose comme ça ma nièce ou ouais
il a tous les non mais vraiment il y
beaucoup en fait de bouquins et chez eux
lorsqu'ils lui même en général quoi mais
beaucoup de je crois que des en plus
d'aidés dès qu'un truc sort il le nie il
y alors ils adorent les sos et en os x
leopard emploi parce qu'il peut voir un
sos et aïssa plus donné envie de jouer
ont parfois pour réfuter les sos c'est
vachement important comme ça ils jouent
pas tu vois les données ils veulent me
mettre une ligne dégueulasse pour le da
de dieu souhaites tu vois comme ça et tu
vois le truc une amputation bientôt le
méchant tu vois mais je le suis c'est
quoi du coup elle souhaite c'est l'ennui
chest hussein fondé sos ouais j'aime ces
quatre des cinq angles aux candidats
bien de quoi c'est prendrait 5
d'apprendre et sac et ses trois d'avancé
à moi je joue ça des foires et c'est
vraiment de la merde mais bon là c'est
complètement nul en c -b scénarii ou le
type le vent un peu tu vois et ça
l'amusé n'a pas trahi leur dit et il
peut être tenté de jouer à wii non non
mais c'est vrai c'est très dangereux
comme monture réfute c'est vrai que s'il
vous prend l'envié de jouer ça je pense
que serena c'est comme ça est ce que il
lui le 64 journal russe où il pas du
tout en russe magnus non je pense pas
qu'ils ce que tu as les excellents
articles je passe il est fait encore
mais guennadi kouzmine
bah oui il faisait des articles de folie
pour soi sans rire dans un monde avait
vu quelques heures mais c'était sérieux
là pour la peine voire annonce n'était
pas les assurait ça c'était dans mes
coups demi est respecté il était seconde
en deux mots non à l'époque il est quand
même au canon source
ouais je crois que c'est qu'un pas
longtemps pour journey with more on je
le connais un petit peu en fait
kouzmine d'accord quand j'ai atteint mon
exposé le voyait de temps en temps j'ai
sonné je rêvais aux olympiades j'ai
appris un truc assez d'eux c'est bizarre
je voyais kuzmin gourévitch dorfman est
en fait qu'est ce qu'ils faisaient là
bas c'est il entraîne et je sais plus
qui est entraîné les îles vierges croit
dortmund est en fait ils affidés qui
donne des entraîneurs ouais ou au qui
payent pour eux un message s'avérait tu
savais je comprends pas pourquoi en fait
sa vie pour faire plaisir aux
fédérations pour qui votre peau oui oui
oui mais je vois passer à solide et
croquer l'italie nous a fait encore mais
après les cavaliers pour en f2 l'a
complètement raide terme et l'italienne
là c'était j'ai toujours eu deux tours
ces deux faux clients les textes et dit
hélène c'est pas possible comme moi et
tu la perds tu la perds c'est pas la
voie était alors ils menacent eux quatre
en plus quelques choix c'est pas fou et
trois peut-être pour essayer de fou 3 km
80 oui j'ai lancé ça et qu'est ce qu'il
est il a massacré les italiennes ont ils
abandonné du coup légèrement pas de sa
cote est sûre c'est la game 4 19 24 30
mais petit bobo rang de géant petit
matin ah oui c'est vrai que c'est plus
sain pour notre chatte que le chat
américain oui j'ai lu mais n'importe
quoi seiko non non tu danseras greffe et
d'ailleurs je m'énerve contre random
américain s'il ya une pause ou quoi wei
à la pause
si je prends la pause n'hésite pas à mon
habitude je deux minutes jouées aux
toilettes vas-y vas-y honteux honteux
reprend du coup j'aurais un peu sur le
tchad joue en plus ils ont tout ce que
vous avez partagé est ce que quelqu es
ce que vous avez fait du coup je vais
remettre un petit lien si vous voulez
partager
je vais vous mettre le pied sur les
partager en profiter c'est un beau match
ans un parent sympa a mené que 2 points
donc ça joue
sajoo de 1.9 à 2.211 points seulement
mais incarnent la gamme anarchy est loin
d'être impressionnant mais il n'est pas
impressionnant d'un camille humaine qui
est inquiétant ce qui est inquiétant
ah ouais si vous voulez partager je vais
mettre le lien vous partagez sur sur
google sur facebook pardon mais c'est
juste que c'est la taille numérique
google
j'aime être en dehors dehors calmes mais
je t'écoute à temps pour revoir
peut-être là la dernière partie vrai
mais on peut on peut faire ça mais je
veux breizh reste ça reste au rcam du
coup aurait longtemps toi d'accord alors
ouais la dernière partie la fedama sept
tours 2 je sais pas ouais mais en fait
il n'est pas atteint il faut qu'ils
aient fait h3 d'abord normalement pour
owen kelly aux sept partis
je pense ça fait peut-être faire h3 p h3
kg 6 mhz tf1 kvh 5,3 à lui manque un
temps alors il m'a perdue ou son temps
alors plus qu'à ses six parfois toi tu
vas être obligé de faire tous ces quatre
temps qu'est ce qui s'est passé du coup
il a fait kebede 2e c'est normal fou aux
six foulées 500 madame b 8 à 4
qu'est ce qui n'était pas normal en fait
ça à 4 il fait d'habitude
voilà il faut pas quatre cavaliers afin
d' habitude
ouais il repart par là bas désir d'amour
set il a fait 3-3 il prenait cas il
prend un caillou c'est toi c'est ça les
parties
comme ça non cavalière feu dame à cet
effet il faisait damas est faux 3 oui
c'est ça frise prise risques pris ce
caillou 7.4 et à user kg 4 pour maxime
jouer tous les trois pour qui et
plusieurs partis comme ça genre faut
prendre ça on avait dans le même temps
oui d'ailleurs il a voulu changer mais
j'espère qu'il va changer il peut plus
jouer c'est dit elle
du coup d'une question qui revient on
demande le top de tes livres des chèques
en français je sais pas si tu es
français qui passe était la meilleure
personne pour proposer cette question
non mais non je suis désolé jusqu'au
dépend en fait comme je le lis l'anglais
du couchage échos des bouquins en
anglais en fait pour cent de mes
bouquins qui sont en anglais alors à
temps est-ce que c'est reparti là je
comprends rien
j'aime bien bouquin d'échec en français
non mais souvent en fait les gens au
chat
il pose une question ces demandes a des
joueurs très forts que ce soit tu sois
favre soit toi que ce soit que ce soit
vlad
il demande qu'elle les qualifs du
conseil pour débuter ou ce genre de
questions mais pas je pense pas que tu
sois soit facile pour toi de répondre
parce que tu lis pas ces livres là en
fait non non moi j'aime bien et kasparov
en fait décasport kisses sur tous ses
matches contre carbox 6 passes quand on
en est pourvu de voir les partis qu'ils
voient c'est sympa quoi tu lis le 6
intéresser des chèques et l'intriguent
tu vois des mac raconte flash - trucks
toi tu vois comment il se prépare
évidemment il parle beaucoup d'échecs et
comment il se prépare pour les
ouvertures et tout ça mais tu vois il ya
la dimension psychologique qui gagnent
beaucoup abordé et finalement il analyse
bien les partis mais tu vois c'est les
gros bouquets il parle beaucoup du match
mais quand même
mais même ces bouquins mygrid
prédécesseur c'est hyper intéressant
ouais oui ça mais c'est ma y penser ça
et c'est les bulls et les matches contre
le carpates oui bah c'est dans le bon
évidemment les autres aussi sur les
autres champions du monde c'est
intéressant mais je trouve que quand il
parle de lui tu vois il est mais après
c'est les bouquins il faut déjà comme un
certain niveau pour l'unir laurent oui
ça tu peux pas rien ça comme on retrouve
web et là toi tu vois wii fit wii pc
changement d'ouverture à tous les
niveaux qua non mais ils sont bien fait
cesser les musts cdma ce thriller
clairement mais bon pas évident donc ça
recommence avec une bouteille et
j'arrive sur la caméra donc prends ton
temps un canton temps mais là faut
scorer à mon avis en direct laurent
faux-pas faut pas laisser aller à plus
de +3 faut pas les avertir donc je
voulais vous le jouez dame aux deux qui
étaient pas ramallah il joue avec trois
ils gagnent là il gagne tout ce temps là
même qui a deux parties mais avec des
temps plus rien après la structure était
pas il ya il a dû réfléchir pendant la
pause ouais il a dû aller parler on va
passer à une fête mais oui naka c'est
lui qui a le le second dans son second
temps il est classé aux alentours de
2002 en 2005 jusqu'à la joue puis le
trou d'air mais c'est quoi en fait très
que de l'ordi mais c'est pas un peu
d'ordre
c'est spécial aux poudres basser qu'il
peut pas lui trop lui parler de ses
parties doit en fait c'est un peu
bizarre
l'impression d'être pote voici
certainement j'espère pour eux donc ton
c6 ouais là c'est embêtant là pour
maxime si elle plonge et 6 ans pascal
leroy ou alors ça pas du tout vrai tu
vas ce même pas tant prend 1,4 en
scannant bref cette web il fait bouger
son aide pour mettre en relief cette non
menace c'est maintenant la suite mais
assez moche cela parce que le match est
très serré et c'est tu sais que c'est
exactement le même scénario que les
derniers matches que j'ai commenté de
maxime contre contre hikaru ya un moment
oui mais c'est pareil les données à la
fois c'est très chaud il ya un moment il
jette de trois parties comme ça et
finalement le plus de plus 3 après il
reste jusqu'au pas ce qui s'était passé
ce qui se ressaisit mais en fait du coup
ils attaquent le bullet à - 2 - 3 et
c'est trop bon voilà donc on avait
pendant la pause dans regarde et se
trouve donc qui joue à 4 maintenant ok
c'est il a renversé les coûts ouais
enfin bon ouais je trouve ça bon des
choix il est quand même impressionnant
hikaru laurent parce que maxime c'est
pas n'importe qui non bien sûr il arriva
le dû complètement le neutraliser avec
les noirs assez facilement c'est
impressionnant quand même alors il faut
remettre en perspective
c'est dommage a maximisé pas je pense au
touquet casting c'est quand même le truc
à la mode avec deux buts d'avancé
donc tu dois avoir une idée cieux jouer
italienne tout le match ils devront
guider sur ça et là on en héros
peut-être à la 6ème italienne ou voilà
chaque fois c'est ça se passe de la même
manière si requis les lignes combien
bahreïn y est moins bien qui change quoi
cet hommage de bon évidemment en
boulette il va changer mais à saissac
c'est un peu too much charme et lycées 4
km mais si c'est quand même très faible
maintenant
ils donneront bien jouer seuil est de
remettre le cros bienvenus laurent way
et c8 maintenant il sert à aider sur la
défense quand même la pression c'est sa
c5 un peu trop ambitieux pour le coup
peut-être peut-être un petit peu un an
portée par l'élan des victoires oui oui
c'est ça et son zéro problème dans
l'italienne des quatre bien joué il
double au centre et aux questions des
charges tout on est bien avec les blancs
juste pour prend cavaliers prendre
menace des cavaliers au cices masseca
web et 5 très agréable voisins la coupe
sera important de restaurer la rai
italienne qui ils menacent de bien se
passer finalement ouais mais ça réglera
pas les problèmes d'ouverture
ouais malheureusement il n'ya pas g4g 4
avec tout simplement l'idée de faire et
avec eric r je suis quand même étonné à
laurent qu'avec les blancs hikaru soit
pas allé sur quatre et des nageurs
écoute il a préparé sa grünfeld larifou
g5 pour pour le match il ya quelques
unes qui sont très mal passé mais là il
a l'air d'avoir dernière partie lui
donne un peu raison d'avoir continué du
coup il a pas vraiment d'idée donc on
verra peut-être dès l'âge d'or dans le
bullet mais a pris europe et je pense
qu'il va continuer à être une fête ça
continue comme ça j'ai cinq maxima il a
surpris que j'ai c'est que sakho
responsable à ton prend 8 ah oui là
maintenant c'est très mauvais pour
ajuster ses 7 et des cinq ans même si
tours un châtelain qui a vu 6-5 annonce
en sera le joli hein
ouais très joli très bonne partie après
le c5 d'osaka moi qui étais vraiment
trop beaucoup trop optimistes mais c'est
pas encore rien à leurs ouailles actis
il va pouvoir
essayez dernier ils menacent bessac je
pense aussi et prince inquiète toujours
à b6 donc ses chevaux j'en sais rien
comme enjeu des 4040 sincèrement et
japonais d'accord le chat ne brille pas
toujours de savoir poser et cette idée
de laisser de liquider quoi on était au
big jo cavaliers samad pas tu vois si
tard il va lui enlever tous les pions a
vraiment lu relu tous les faits mais ce
que tu m'as vraiment de prendre ou non
sa maintenance à une tête de mule
alors est ce que tu veux pas essayer de
faire un statu quo et toi venir te
battre avec ton avatar je veux à sa 3
maintenant et après on y va jouer le
coup de kébé set ça c'est nul 1
normalement mais bon
ah ouais mais il a le droit qui est un
peu plus près quand même c'est pas c'est
pas signer une position du roi noir
quand même un peu inquiétante des
métiers je te menace dès maintenant des
clips ranger 3 k voyage 6 km 5 km et
trois femmes et si tu gardes le crash
oui je le pousse et ya la barrière
après faut encore leur réalisme et puis
en plus pour mater l'honneur c'est pas
évident ce matelas il est sage 80 et
bien sache 4 liquide tout cela s'est
terminé
nul dommage mais tu vois là sur les
trois dernières parties le scénario
comment ils souhaitent se passe à 2
partira telata une semi occasions de
revenir j'ai l'impression vraiment de
revenir ceux de revivre le mauvais
scénario des autres matchs
pressez pas fait un pli même en bullet
tout peut arriver lors en bullet fidh
ce que maxingvest s'est pas non plus
n'importe qui un oui bon je m'ajoute non
mais j'ai vu joueurs match oui je veille
devant donc l'accueil pranger 3 avec
l'épreuve 4 c'est un ami de kate tu
pousses un chien très choqués ou hkd
d'abord tu vois pour être sûr alors j'ai
quatre cavaliers ou 3 ol3 est prolongée
cas et bref 300 s'en fout qu'il perdait
4 way du coup on prend et 24 épreuves 4h
3 pour être sûr l'addition
je veux te prends mais ça c'est nul
théorique il a joué qui sait s'il a fait
chuter ses intermédiaires
ouais il a fait jusqu'à 13 qu à vivre
d'accord j'ai quatre cailloux 3 oui dans
le chat que naka on peut l'être c'est
dieu ouais -fh 3 d'abord ouais ouais ça
fait ni automatique
ouais surface comme ré achat l'est pas
alors un problème de connexion pour naka
non partie interrompue regardez fait des
grimaces quoi les problèmes de connexion
n'est alors ouais ça ç'a permis
d'interrompre la partie de la relance
est malheureusement j'espérais qu'on ait
un forfait que le fair play la française
bah oui mais non enfin on écoute ses
mecs parfumé tu joue vite quoi sert le
conseil qu'on a retenu de la vidéo
laurent et c'est ça ouais j'étais pas
très bien dans ce match est important
normand l'a tous fait un jeu rassure
hésité aussi marcus est pas faite jeudi
la casse au texte est loin pour aller
vers les 5 minutes à chaque fois encore
damas un exemple charge peut user d'un
v6 avancer ça mais le camp à fond dames
des deux noms mais ça on a déjà eu non
non pas exactement la dame en v6 mind
and death is alive
la dame b trois ans comprend les pieds
dresser sa faut arriver à bien vu la
finale dames mais trop mal mais ça me
semble écrasant pour les ans dans la
colonne sais mais bon y'a pas toi c'est
certain j'ai l'impression dont ed 8 seul
coup tu es bon tu pourras même largué la
kalach avec tout reprend 17 francs b5
derrière taylor je vais c'est que les
pièces d autres en fait wayne ne fait
pas avec tes pieds sur terre moi oui non
ouais je suis là non moi tu peux tu peux
pas m'accuser le truc de série juan là
il est facile de taxer les pièces d oc
avec moi ça marche pas les miennes sa
part encore plus vite
mais en fait il peut pas vraiment faire
à 4 à cause du sacrifice de qualité
maintenant à être avant 17 h f a dit ça
pour me pourquoi il fait ça pour me
contredire pourquoi ce qui se passe
autour des 7 je comprends
ok il a joué donc tout reprend faut
prouver ça qui est puis prise en a
quatre et puis bonne chance et comme tel
plan des 5 c'est juste normal sa cuisse
de qualité il est bon un cessez le feu
tellement un fada de réfléchir et va
alors plus le pion à ici serait mal
placé 1 quel joueur que redoute le plus
car ces aides
j'ai envie de répondre laurent quel
joueur que redoute le plus j'ai envie de
répondre lui même mais mais il pense que
caruana ils sont meilleurs chargeurs
sont affairés disait hier c'est ce que
j'ai dit hier dans la vidéo je pense
il espérait vraiment que ce soit lui qui
soit celui de challenger pour avoir le
décharge le plus intéressant à ses yeux
des gens qui se disent c'est être là
d'un le à ouidah je suis avec l'acrobate
est marrante cette grave alors été alors
là vraiment j'avais jamais vu ça je lui
ai parlé et il savait pas que tu t'étais
filmé mais ça l'amusé je sentais que le
sujet le sujet le musée pas trop ouais
enfin tu vois j'ai pas assister là
dessus
tata sortir que l'hostilité ouais c'est
pas un truc qui le
j'avais gagné le tourment et tout ça
donc ce n'était pas grave de ce type
n'est d'avoir faire de leur faire perdre
l'effet nul mais bon mais ici j'avais
fait une bonne partie au moins tu penses
où je pense il a respecté la partie où
ils font si tu es vraiment de la merde
on sais pas j'ai pas chez taj parce
qu'ils essaient d'oublier cette partie
réussi à envoyer c'est fou quand il a
essayé de mettre un pur en d3 envers sa
fille cécile bourlaka pas ce qu'il faut
c'est ça ouais
hu il va la gagner cette partie
ce serait beau il faut jouer aux cadres
non mais t'es pas mal car et non mais
t'es pas mal on fait ce qu'on peut on a
des ans des truc c'est que mon à 4-4
cameron a des petits écrans ce pas
facile de rester à tomber à toi un non a
priori va pas taire ou non ils ont peu à
perdre tout reprend surprend et mais il
va parler gagné non plus on sait pas on
voit des deux tours à deux je te prends
g2a ouais tu prends g2 j'avais pas vu
mais j'apprends f6 et oui non tu vois il
le fait pas et il protège le pion y
rejouer le finlandais reste mal terrible
et je vous laisse le shaq
alors je vois ce par quoi qu'ils aient
jamais tu menaces peut-être
je me lasse de c'est parce que tu
menaces au final sur 24 faire bref cette
île à fait correct et tu peux aller
rechercher son pion g2 que tu voulais
faire ta leur prêtez pas au 5ème ferrer
5 7 6 non un arrière droit toujours fait
la grimace de partout c'est
insupportable
l'arrière-garde il refait une tête de
comme quoi il est choqué de ne pas être
gagnée en quoi c'est incroyable ah oui
il arrête pas et c'est qu'il était était
complètement derrière cette prime et en
fin d'article plein de tours prend 17 et
pour prouver 5 l et depuis on pourra
qualité ça comme une très bonne tête et
un ans qui joue koala qui joue pour
gagner entre 10 et ouais ok c'est rien
tout est foutu couleurs opposées nul a
eu raison
bon et maintenant ils vont enfin ses
citoyens de cette possible aaa enfin
voilà enfin c'est toujours mieux que les
italiennes apparemment il sera pas moins
bien il peut refaire le tour 2 2 de
magnus non
4 c'est soit qu'ils aient trouvé ce tour
2 ou pas d'ailleurs nom commun qui est
ouest sur deux peut-être magnus lui même
non non non non rires il est pas très
bon mari d'un recherche d'idées dans les
ouvertures
c'est vraiment un fait étonnant c'est
vraiment étonnant s'est amorcé la
première fois de ma vie que je critique
magnus à peu près si tu veux la cm c'est
parfois c'est même épatant bizarre non
hop ça tu as pensé je crois que c'est
sans cesse de jouer
bon évidemment tu mets dans un truc qui
a toujours des choses intéressantes mais
non mais non
non c'est passé pas et il a il n'aime
pas trop ça ce genre de truc autour de
10 ans à villars ce que pour un champion
du monde quand même
n'ont-ils étude d ouverture générale
intéresse mois que doit méjean après ils
pensent qu'ils travaillent pas mais en
fait c'est pas du tout ça il fait plein
d'exercices
il y beaucoup de choses et on regarde
beaucoup de parties réfléchit à plein de
choses mais juste il est pas là repoussé
le bouton ordinateur pour savoir pour
savoir si les blancs 0,40 ou pas qu'on a
du coup ça m'étonne pas qu'ils aiment
bien les sos kouassi ats à la musique
italienne une berlinoise qui voit là une
berline aux taureaux assez marrant non
parfois ils proposent des idées mais par
rapport à son niveau tu vois c'est pas
qu'il proposerait à mes toiles paroisse
haut niveau tu t'attendes rien au mieux
sur substrat uchronique avant donc oui
oui ça change mais il est brisé sa vie
qui bouillonne et qui travaillent 24
heures sur 24 en faisant avec trois
ordinateurs tu vois un qui tourne sur la
position l'autre qui en fait tu vois ses
idées bien là les trois pièces tu vois
élevé au moins il faut pas perdre tu l'a
un peu tu vas peut passer la dm1 va pas
se mentir non mais attends 13 points à
damerey way foutu sa foutue ça oui oui
pression trop ouverte la série
ouais et la paire de fou comme ça aussi
même peut-être tour d un formulaire et
une tour je pense mais à prendre
l'option m'écoute pas il y aura cinq
fois bêtement t'es sûr que ses paires
dans sa tête fut un enfant quand même se
voir son mal organisé je te mets le 2e
assises non elle vous donne un mais
trois noms alors assis direct m6 directs
savaient dam des trois acteurs ou
n on en est à la tête mais je crois
qu'il le pays perde élection de partout
et laurent ainsi si hatem détroit aussi
arrivé au lycée ça a fait mal jouer
maintenant ok peut-être peut-être foutu
non il est obligé de sacrifier son rang
tu as quand même beaucoup plus de
chances à une forteresse avec les deux
fous alors attention voilà il va faire
savoir ouais je te fais ça je te mets h5
g6 et peut-être j'écarte la tête g4
direct rien faire j'ai six ou dix sept
et ugtm et f4 pour faire un truc vite je
pense pas mais déjà on va pas la perdre
laurent a eu dans l'état la raison en
fait foi les rails et un petit peu jours
comme ça tu vas plus qu'à travailler à
fléchir projet cissé g5 way g5 qui est
quand même de la mer et des récits cela
finissait plus mais magnus ne crois pas
pour forteresse lammer fait rage de
karuïa kinsa n'a pas dissuadé non s'en
fout tu crois pas quand même là par ici
que ça existe où il refuse même bien que
ça existe mais en général ils croient
pas à une soirée z'ont pas mal et où il
a écrit g7 tout de suite et se pressent
à toi lentement
mais attention si je faisais faire dame
c7 est passé droits devant et où
j'hallucine en es tu vas faire genre f6
jordan saisi la petite 1m des 4 life
s'ajuste les dames les cas c'était pas
terrible ça même si on peut faire rage 5
qui on prend et d'abris 4 peut être vous
faire dame veuve de encore si le sol
puis on regarde aïn azel justice marc
gales a passé l'orangé 600 ça j'en ai
oublié
c'est bizarre comme matériel c'est pas
quelque chose qu'on voit tous les jours
marie je crois que le roi il s'est
échappé a priori tu passe pas trop quand
même maintenant c'est une barrière de
corail en fait ouais
un matin à temps
afr fois ses marges et aucune c est qu
une pièce la république pièce tu avais
peut-être quelqu'un qui peut dire dans
le chat mais ça va être nul à date ça je
crois que c'est dieu ouais je pense et
beaucoup y aviez se plonger quoi c'est
quand même fou enfin plus ou moins la
même avec la samp plongée c'est dommage
mais du coup ils peuvent lire les tables
basses sans plonger ce que ça donne ils
veulent récupérer en mettant sous deux
angles
d'accord ils passent de 30 co agressive
avec pulp ion qui aurait pu échanger
oui bon il va la récupérer la non pas
sur ces faits cette dame c'est cinq rois
c7 la rose 6 il fait encore état d'âme à
4 ima sera animée par ima sera l'ami 8
roi fou des 8es et prédicateur avait
peur pareil
allez c'est pas le qi pourrait peut-être
le mettre en exergue le talent il va la
perdre
voilà attend serait mais qu'est-ce qui
se bat bien on va commencer à croire à
un truc c'est qu'il ya toujours foule et
7 en finale
qu'est ce qui les porte alors là c'est
cette partie sa mort et la panique
perdre patins ah bah c'est déjà pas mal
qu'ils y perpètrent messi avait pas eu
le pion g ouais ça serait intéressant de
savoir quoi haye adam dame s'est vite
dame des sept matches ah c'est beau
assez bien joué assez bien joué droit à
un magnifique aldama schwyz et bien
jouer laurent c'est magnifique
elle était belle salle à
ouais bonifie alors on parle pas du tout
complètement inattendu à l'essai du bien
laurent l'incroyable le damage fui ça
c'était il revient à s'allumer voyant la
tête de deux carreaux à temps ils disent
que c'est hikaru qui a refusé nul
incroyable
ouais mais jouer pour superbe partie je
suis pas sûr parce qu'une proposition de
nul je suis pas sûr que c'est sage en
train de regarder pour qui a proposé
donc il revient mais si c'est que ça va
me faire rattraper sur celle là
[Musique]
tout cas fantastique le match vraiment
surtout très intéressant et on a eu mais
non je n'ai pas du tout vu demain suite
et bah c'est très joli c'est vraiment
une tactique mais ça n'empêche que moi
je trouve que mec à moi quand même très
bien défendu la sdat ma cheville qui
histoire devienne pas et qui fait que
sur wade huitième pour age 2 échecs
donc il ya plus de dames mais ça devait
être nulle à nbc
mais il a cherché à le forcer tout de
suite voir pour passe des formes pendant
qu'en plus on peut le comprendre
là il se passe quoi pourquoi ils
adoption dès qu'elles risquent pas faire
damas trois pour y siéger avec du fou
ces cinq je suis pas ses mots je veux
pas donner ce truc d'emprunt d'oeil à
pousser 3 qui fait très très mal
fréquence par tour s'est vite mais bon
ça ne peut pas donner les pions centraux
comme ça il faut avoir quelque chose de
vraiment ultra complet voilà la non la
saillie se fait dominer la sur la voie
notamment lui conseiller de changer nous
a pas écoutés et lus raisons il a eu
raison
alors que maxime est conseillé de
changer il nous a écouté et il a eu
raison du foot et syna qui a échangé il
y aurait eu raison aussi comme c'est ce
qui ne pouvait avoir à attendre cccc
tendu parce que du coup il peut avoir
une grosse attaque maxime ci prend d2 et
qui te colle avait commencé un irritant
l'aventuré actuellement il ya plus de
voitures plus central à vos pions tu
vois voir faut consolider damage quête
d'amd vite tu vois tu parles aventure ça
peut ça peut marcher mais ou pas donc
c'est très très risqué quoi tu vois t'as
pas besoin de ça
comment je te prendrai deux mois je
prends des deux chansons qu'il a pas
beaucoup d'échec parce que si f si je
crois je vire ya pas il n'y a pas
d'arrêt suite à un pur congressistes
quand même sur d'un pro d2 à sémalens
écoute je voulais faire pour ses reins
damev six échecs
6 et je me disais non là je vais faire
tu reproches c'était gsm non en fait
elle est sûre je pense que surprendre si
c'est un truc assez joli ces dames f2
ouais bien jouer laurent ouais je les
laurent je te remercie avec l'asie avec
la saison que après twilight et sa
lettre f 6 3 h 6 d'apprendre cette fois
c'est ça partirait et il menace
ça va je crois et il ya des mecs de
quais toujours dans les deux sens juin
la fusion de la nulle c'est ça ou alors
il ya d'ar est roi où il a très bien
juste à face et a mis les deux positions
et comme son de prusse et dix matches
joués 2 au bout d encore alors fait voir
la cam
oui trop la vie puisse les yeux comme ça
rien par moment il n'était pas très
content mais ils vont ils encore mieux à
quel pleurnicheuse oui mais je vois pas
en fait pourquoi il est mieux
bref ou des six c'est exactement je
pensais prendre un iphone à morat je me
fous des six est ce que m'en fous il est
pas mieux que tient m
alors je fais un coup de pouce 5 au coup
d'après pourquoi quel est mon problème
[Musique]
si je me fais pas ma télévision
c'est ce qui fait
ouais et maintenant je pousse l attend
[Musique]
je commençais mais les doigts après tout
si ce qui va continuer dans le père du
noise by retour dans l'île
c'est un peu plus ok non non tout mais
pas ça ces choix ciblés et qu'erdf 3g 3g
va pas quelque chose mais il trouve il
trouve vraiment rien dans le dans
l'italienne c'est un problème alors s'il
a changé coûte que pau elle a peu vu kg
4 copenhague tu dois changer tout coûte
que coûte
je crois ils marchent tellement moi je
mettrais à des 4 1 en finale mais bon
ouais ouais
même si claude va jouer un derby même
temps y avoir une idée mais moi je vais
bien ce que tourer vers la saluer
correspondent pas mal mais l'a
finalement il a eu un petit truc tu vois
j'ai pas pourquoi il n'a pas répété d'un
quart des cas on nous dit que dans le
jazz qui prennent une master class sur
sur les italiennes ce soir ouais ben moi
j'ai du mal avec les italiennes aussi
mais avec les noirs ça avance at home ce
qu'ils font c'est ce qu'il a fait là que
moi tout le tout le match à moi j'aime
bien ce qu'il a fait et position très
solide là c'est celle qui se passe le
plus mal carrément quasiment en cela par
un fort pressing cavaliers f5 a beau
centre du plein jeu du d5 maintenant
pourquoi as tu vas l'a fait et le keller
j-6 est toujours mal perçue dans ces
structures voyage et 3 qui va arriver
natama 4 pas mal
pas prendre à 5 ici ouais je commente
quoi c'est un peu un peu un peu too much
as lu tu prends tes bras mais il veut
faire trouver c'est sûr d'un premier 5
m3 gt2 c'est sûr mais il va fermer 4
maintenant je pense
il veut te dire que tu auras tu réussis
jamal poussé bailly va essayer de le
prendre je peux faire b3 mais bon c'est
chez b 3 tu pourras plus poussée mais il
a en plus été mieux avec les bleus ah
oui c'est pas facile et vous c'est déjà
mieux que d'être moins bien comme on l'a
été
oui bien sûr mais c'est la première et n
qui se passe à peu près correctement
tu pousses un peu je pousse gentiment
visant à les vagues il va la gagner ça
le rend fou qu'il faut pas qu'ils
démarrent les bulles est en retard
d'accord faut vraiment pas qui démarre
l'émulateur tard quand je l'avais c'est
une interview de maxime il m'avait dit
qu'il voulait démarrer à plus de +36
d'accord n'est pas encore il reste en
même temps là je vais dire ça tout de
suite
il reste 28 minutes pour tenter un truc
d'accord donc est ce le temps est plus
de +3 ça commence déjà à être ni des
gens des notes
oui mais bon s'ils commencent déjà à
l'italienne qui remet transparente
c'est fou ce machin s'il arrive pas tu
vois s'il arrive enfin avant les bulles
est ce vraiment à cause de ces parties
avec les blancs finalement je vous aime
pas c est ce qu il un score positif avec
des blancs je pense pas je pense pas
cavalier aussi side up
non puisque j'aurais fais tu aimes ça
non mais qu'est aussi sert bien
j'ai quoi sur qriocity ont entraîné
l'arrêt d'un pro même tout reprend oui
c'est le matin dont le f2 pas mal sûr
qu'il veut faire qui réussissent et
menaces matt est sûre et g4 et fait que
les os 6 comme ça et ça et matt la barre
et j'ai quatre cas mais aussi ailleurs
haytham 7/6 et là c'est plus fort
blessés plus fort ce que les tours qui
sont très bien j'ai très très bien joué
à la déviance à y défend bien
bahia dès 6 heures en l'air quand même à
faire un échange pas évidemment h3 plus
échec
mastour f7 et surtout recettes ses
atours et figurants bienvenus il y avait
encore songé set mais c'est pas ça
commence à et que ne commence le pain en
fait trois sets et surtout recettes en
fait j'ai tout reprendre et si tout
simplement pareil tu peux aussi prendre
le pion et je double plus vrai tueur ait
à la f6 au calme écoute facile et w9 de
prendre ou la g5 tams et de tempo ce qui
le battait pas il ya les rages sein
quelques regrets surtout à vii
il ne boitait pas c'est pas sûr alors
attends ya pas du tours fc twente est
terminée ou pas assez sûre il part en h5
il aura gâché
j'ai fait un coup de dame prend tout
reprend et tour h7 par exemple fait
attendait du calcul à faire
en fait c'est chaud laurent lasalle
alors évidemment ça pue pour les peaux
et noir s'est alors complètement foutu
mais il faut encore finaliser ce n'est
pas évident d'amd un bien joué ils
menacent tous rêvent cette fine tout cas
ils une menace d'un match 5 et d'aller
mater qu'est ce que ça joue bien laurent
c'est très très bien en plus c'est
logique de garder l'âme tu vois pas ce
que son rang à sept îles est en train de
se faire mater
ah c'était beau d'amener un français aya
3d coûtent des sommes incroyables damage
suite d'amd un cd coup ça a l'air de
rien quand tu regardes comme ça si tu
les vois tu dis ouais on essaie de
prouver qu'on n'était même pas on était
à dix mille lieues de même d envisager
le problème c'est que quand tu envisages
tu le jour ait quoi que tu la tiens tu
jouais à c'est un bon petit d'où une
feuille donc il est revenu il y revient
en tant il est revenu à hauteur et tu
vois c'est dommage ce petit passage avec
le petit passage à vide là la partie
avec les blancs en 18 coups la cuisse h
derrière et pas beaucoup plus glorieuses
un ouais c'est maintenant qu'à effet des
parties parfois passe à côté mais il
égale à 50 % à payer quand même là ça
faut dire que il a perdu une bonne fête
aussi laurent h3 dacca - paris qui est
un peu spécial moi j'ai l'impression les
blancs sont venus en fait dans cette
position-là pas et maxime les joues bien
oui enfin mais normalement il devrait
pas voilà
absolument le pain le paraît daboub et
c'est peut-être dans beaucoup de parties
il a laissé faire finalement ils
envoyaient les pions bizarre pas comme
ça et le plus grand avec la phalange de
f4 cinq des six mois et non pas ça a
paru si j'aurai à bala c'est tellement
vrai quoi oui elle se joue ici cela
ouais terminé alors il peut pas tu peux
pas laisser je peux pas laisser faire
l'a400m et si c'est possible je sais
tellement tout match que déjà une
nouvelle fois c'est un petit craquage en
fait certains qui ont repris la phalange
pas à cette esthétique de jouer cinq ans
c'est dommage il n'y a pas de seins et
pis ils attendent quoi c'était joli
conte avec trois ou quatre des cinq
après les 4 5 et 6 ans 8 à 5 ou 6 17 mai
à ce titre dames ces sept là non chaque
coup et ni piste où aller secourir
tellement gagnant à je comprends pas
pourquoi maxime il craque comme ça c'est
la troisième qui donne quoi c'est
tellement dommage là chez c'est le même
temps les ouvertures
maintenant ils commencent être en prise
avec les noirs et avec des blancs est
pas on va pouvoir la cia et blanc ça se
passe aussi bien
il commença à pêcher après tout aussi ça
va ça vient
il ya un coup comme ça qui est énorme et
j'ai déjà vu ça mais bon non mais
laurent le truc c'est vraiment ça c'est
que j'ai l'impression que les efforts
qui doit fournir pour égaliser à chaque
fois ça le salé puiser du coup ici tu
vois il enchaîne mal quoi allez l'adorer
déjà une menace au 4 l énorme ce 4 ok tu
as déjà des problèmes
je ne sais même pas tu tu essayes
d'égaliser georges te fait route france
et 4
pourquoi d'arc et le monde je vais tenir
ici mais aucun témoin bien donc non la
non là c'est dommage voilà il salue je
pense que ça joue parce que c'est
tellement serré ils sont tellement
proches que ça joue quand même qu'ils se
fassent tenir en bullet c'est non mais
tu vois je comprends que ils veulent pas
montrer ses ouvertures et tout ça parce
que c'est chez ce point comme et et
finalement c'est pas tournoi tu vois qui
compte pour le classement qui va avoir
une incidence tu vois mais quand même tu
peux préparer une petite variante à voir
le match bon c'est peut-être qu'il est
préparé ça va pas marcher après c'est
pas possible de tout de tout réparer
pendant le match
est ce que tu penses que c'est toi sur
internet ils peuvent prendre encore plus
de d'importance dans l'est dans les
années à venir et que les joueurs les
prennent budget le prennent plus au
sérieux
je pense que nous et je pense qu aimer
le pam c'est que ça doit pas être ouvert
un à tout le monde
ces jours là on peut leur faire
confiance oui mais c'est ce que fait de
chasse comme en fait ils ferment ils
ferment quand même là que c'est assez
bien
ben non c'est pas mal moi je trouve ça
et franchement
quoi de mieux pour que de ça pour
définir qui le maire joie 5 le format
est bon pour définir le meilleur c'est
que quand même compté à 3h30 un match
dans cette can en sûr on en parle avec
fabre on se demande s'ils savaient même
pas presque plus de valeur qu'une partie
n'ont aucun aucun championnat de billes
en voyant toute façon c'était bon on n'a
qu'à moi c'est spécial parce qu'il est
vraiment il est vrai en mêlant rapide et
ambitieux que quand partis classiques
s'arrêter comme ça en tout cas c'est à
plus de valeur qu'un championnat du
monde de beats à mon avis ouais j'suis
d'accord il ya moins de deux variantes
que dans un jeu rugueux en double et de
fait c'est clair
et puis le fait de jouer pendant
longtemps tu passes le rideau adverse de
l'eau tu tues tu peux changer si de
position talent tant de tu peux tu
adaptes et tu peux ça me fait penser à
des matches de tennis en cinq sets
tu as vraiment le temps de jauger de
match mais heureusement maxime mais ne
peut pas tenter m dames échec les allées
dallées mach 1,8 là-bas de assez sûr
qu'il va tenter un truc comme ça mais
bon tu vois je peux traverser b4 par
exemple c'est pas clair tu veux faire
quoi
disons dame premier 4 non je vais faire
kiev 5 et 7 e menacés du tour prend des
cinq cailloux cette voie là non sap ecc6
bien gens les uns et m6 pour empêcher
les magouilles mais ça devient bien
déprimant pour les pour les blancs non
mais le truc c'est vraiment un laurent
si on compare les efforts faits pour les
deux joueurs pour gagner leur parti
c'est là que tu vois henri kona qui
domine rideau minutemen que d'un point
ouais mais tu sens il n'y a pas eu à
jouer sur l'italienne sur b3 il a fait
des sacs et puis voilà il était bien
tout de suite à une aria et de sorciers
tu sens qu'il refusait les paris maxime
agueh etc avait été belge doit damage
frites dam des séquelles des coups de
dents creuses mais quelques parts a
vraiment l'impression d'avoir fait un
truc sur terre-battue l'a1
un machin ou talent mais qui fait qui
fait des beaucoup qui gagnent des beaux
jeux et puis ta l'otan fassent un mot il
break à 0,40
tu as fait trois double fautes quoi en
fait ouais ouais ça puzzle et du coup en
fait c'est vrai il y en a un qui joue
mieux meilleur tri à 8,7 un petit
reprise sont lents mais il n'y a rien
desperado 2 pour moi le plus rapide en
trois puis cinq fois qu'ils espèrent
accrocher à faire les trois partis qui
perd en trois plus un c3 cadeau un sac
c'est dommage mais il a perdu laquelle
en fait aller les deux dernières haies
c'est la toute première en fait il avait
perdu la toute première c'était je crois
que c'est une femme qui avait mal tourné
après l'italienne du 3 + 1 d'accord
ouais ça qu'il est un petit passage à
vide il est comment l'un d'eux mais bon
mois d'août c'est quand même beaucoup
mali les niveaux sont tellement serrés
laurent oui allez vous inquiète oui
voilà b 5e sac voilà c'est comme ça que
j'aime bien c'est vrai que si on regarde
et magnus on serait encore confiant
parce que magnus en bullet il avait
donné une petite mission à dakar pour f3
m'étais pas du vrai pu l'être c'est ce
qu'il a expliqué manu séduire plusieurs
oui oui mais bon et kendrick belle leçon
de deux ans plus un en permanence offert
au père un père hikaru oui là bas tout
le match il avait aussi fait quoi soit
+4 ouais mais c'est un peu le même
scénario que la chair qu'on america ou
qui dominait qu'ils un max d'efforts et
puis qui doit cesser toujours ce même
scénario où tu es tu es obligé de sortir
des grosses games pour les gagner et
puis l'autre il est en contrôle quoi tu
as l'impression qu'ils contrôlent le
match quand même adam g 5 l'a peut-être
tour c'est un qui arrive on se fait
savoir m haies h 4 h la tam f4 ouais non
et bien là tu vois il faut que f5 et
bien ça
j'ai beaucoup aimé
cinq baies 5 allez on arrête le pire
c'est même si objectivement c'est
peut-être pas très bon tu vois c'est du
blitz tu joues actifs à ça se
compliquera il aime ça me prendrait
quatre échecs ça aurait même joué la
finale dame prend est enceinte je vois
cette entente avec vos câbles et qui
vient le 4 et depuis l'an passé lié à ce
que tu as le temps des 4,3 g 8 et poussé
4 octobre
ouais island abandonné non messieurs à
ses fins aulas mais voilà c'est mieux ça
pourquoi laurent j'ai l'impression qu'on
est en train de craquer je pense que
c'est physique un long bail
psychologique physique lui verser c'est
plus dans la tête si il a ça fait trop
de points qui sont lâchés d'affilée
c'est impossible en écoute à l'euro mais
c'est d'accord voilà un petit il lui
faudrait une belle partie tu vois là une
belle combine très qui le remettent un
peu dedans bien 15 minutes on parlait de
d'attaquer les bulles est à plus de
puces prendre et qu'on n'avait pas le
temps et en l'espace de dix minutes près
des optimistes parce que tu veux non non
on a en a on vient prendre mais en 33
points en l'espace de 12 minutes laurent
trois points on est d'accord ok c'est
pas c'était pas les meilleures sauces
minutes du match et la peau mieux ou pas
d'ailleurs allé hier j'ai pas laurent
fau tu fasses un tour de magie faut que
je suis un faux jeu des verts yve fois
qu'il n'a pas joué la finale de la
berlinoise ce soir non mais il ya beau
répertoire comme moi qu'est ce que tu
veux il joue derby des amis de la
berlinoise
alors qu'est ce qui se passe dans sur
l'écran de la caméra à la main annoncé
c'est bizarre ça clignote
c'est drôle ça c'est pas mal mais il
s'est hissé prévu un truc c'est pas
possible il
il a prévu un écran spécial c'est un
fond vert derrière il le fait clignoter
il ya quelque chose va laurent
je sais pas complètement parena cas par
messager ça j'ai jamais vu encore en
speech à ce mec qui à l'écran ou ge qui
clignote derrière c'est parce qu'il a
écrit trois parties d'affilée c'est quoi
le délire est complètement taré là il
avait pas d'obstacle à jenson qui bouge
la tête de partout que se regarde il
dégoté une oraison leur match qu'est ce
qu'il fout encore les coûts koudou et ce
l'est d'alger 5
c'est lamentable
et comme on gagne cette finale
t'as pas de simples ça se gagne salon
non ça ne se gagne pas enfin tout est
possible en route mais à 5 b ci soit ils
auraient dû faire goût de becker dommage
ça la magnus il aurait pu la prendre à
icare - il en a gagné
l'aïe a peut-être à perdre maxime l'un
gelant paraît quand même nom terme avait
gagné une peine à la scène que phil cup
et qu on soit un échec alors je pense
qu'il y aura projet 5 marrant que tu
veux monter à tu montes a été sans
prendre mais je vois jamais 5 et roy
pranger 5e purge ici ce qui va être en
prise derrière un truc avec les planches
ne pas faire grand chose à voir rires
non non ça va être nul à bosser sur ces
questions non mais elle était formidable
à l'asim que phil cap la magnus prière
la finale tour qui a gagné ah ouais
génial match et me coucher en plus à
minuit un peu dégoûté tu vois je dis
c'est quand même dommage de pas votre
quoique à la dernière et je me lève et
je regarde mais vraiment parent ou enfin
bah ouais ouais
parce que tu dois way est incroyable
safia de tours c'était extraordinaire
attends ça s'anime un peu laurent pour
gagner je prends ça comme on va
peut-être la perdre peut-être mais il
joue pour gagner
ouais ben youssef 5 pour gagner
clairement il veut vraiment le ya plus
de respect alors là car la torre tu fais
quoi avec
tu vois moi aussi j'ai web steinmann
il ya un double angle de faire tourner
pour prendre quatre
les moyens de prendre des deux ouais bon
ces quatre là c'est une décision à
prendre c'est pas évident c'est parce
qu'il faut faire
b4 et donc au prochain tour laurent le
vainqueur de ce match je jouerai contre
20 jouera contre contre les bonnes la
belle et bonnier pas très bon bein ouai
je pense que ça va être
je les ai joués tous les vents n'y ait
pas boisseau il est plus ambigu qui lui
était impressionnant il eût été je
trouve pas directement quelques années
où il est quand même nettement tout en
2008 2009 laurent possible mais enfin en
tout cas way n'importe lequel des deux
maximum
on n'a qu'à partira donc favori ouais y
va la gagner
surtout quand bullet règle a souri les
vans et pas où ils vont pas s'entraîner
mais bon ils égalent arrivée en 2001 et
il a perdu cette finale incroyable bond
avec 48 15 ans on va pas se mentir à y
jouer quand minable ils se moquent de
lui hors série 20
alors montre moyennées sur bijoux g3 tu
vas jarreau maxime baca koné simpson un
petit peu c'est terrible c'est terrible
en petits gris dame pourquoi pas pour
faire tilter georges se joue autant
d'ouvertures maintenant je te ajouté
cela retirera ses réveils j'aille jouer
quand de rich media des longtemps où il
faisait ça et ça m'énervait s'amender
fois tu vois pas ce qu il battu jouer
espagnol des îles by trees panique pas
je leur dit david bagshaw un candidat
oui enfin bon il bat toutefois
l'ouverture que la a donc à la fête ça
rend fou quoi tu vois c'est la parole à
l'ouverture ça vient pas d'ouverture
battre et pour fertile que le mec il m'a
dit que c'était après ses exploits pour
ça
juke est un qui est un excellent joueur
de poker d'ailleurs bas prix pour cacher
dans l'or en chine mais il paraît que
c'est un jeu de full tilt poker sera
jamais joué mais il paraît que c'est un
jeu de tarés ouais c'est un jeu très
fort et qu'il ya de la variance de folie
ouais exacte du coup tu recommandes
j'adore il des joueurs liégeois
il envoie cavaliers 5 pourquoi fait-on
v8 ouais il n'avait pas trop le choix
est moins bien il ya une catalane catane
de rêve pour les blancs j'ai déjà le cas
hier c'est qu'ils ont pu pour jamais ces
cinq bon heureusement qu'il a par ok si
j'apparais si j'avais rockets ce serait
limite abordable ila fait qu'il prend
tout reprendre b5 vous efficace en bonne
taille et de fou et je fais tu vas
prendre prendre kébé 4 mètres le fiancé
ici c'est fou et b4 genre prêt à manger
de fou
j'arrive pas à tant qu'européens 11 ans
kelly détroit il aurait pu en mieux je
pense j'ai assez d'accord sur le haut 5
france et 6 qui ont quant à eux y aller
là et maxime ce bail tout un peu de jeu
est ce que je peux faire [ __ ] ans et 6
tu reprends tes prince est
alors il a passé laurent mais laurent 1
on est dans le dur hein on est dans le
dur
ça fait quand même quatre consécutives
c'est incroyable ce que ces moments il a
lancé aux belles parties on était comme
des fous en disant qu'ils avaient
égalisé puis 9
ouais c'est ce domaine-là c'est très bon
égalité leur en parler de +3 oui oui
nous on espérait plus trois mais je
revenais à égalité on espérait faire + 3
et on se demandait si on avait le temps
d'en gagner 3 ou pas en fait
et l'autre a réussi à nous en mettre 4
et là on est très très mal sa dérive
d'aplomb les boulettes
bon il peut s'il ya une seule a choisi
ça peut être ça peut être un petit tour
dans les paniers à trois points et a
pris les clous et calais ou quatre
barrages ou d'un cahier prendre à kiev
trois étaient pas moins de wes air sympa
ça c'est pas mal aussi parce que le pion
c3 maintenant et des cas où tu la gagnes
c'est la non mais en tout cas il est
plus ou moins bien
oui même mieux vincent petit set ferrer
ou g5 fois s4i les trois bien joué tour
d un way tendance est infondée hafjell a
pas su à temps il ya et h2o am et attend
il te fixes les pions il va il va te
faire ces choses c'est vrai nom s'est
vendu parce qu'en fait c'était bien joué
ils donnent le plus longtemps ici en
angola
non c'est loin d'être nul salon wii dans
fast mlc plus nul mais c'est pas pas sûr
j'ai appliqué ce genre prem's exception
il sera fixé à l'ale dame mais oui c'est
par respect non c'est mieux maintenant
g6 tepa tijd voilée en erreur d'avoir
voilà je pense que c'est nul maintenant
chercher facile en plus il a proposé nu
il n'y a pas dû entendre
non j'ai fils c'est le nom tu peux pas
faire justice elle est super heureux
naka c'est horrible assaf regarde passer
à la fois ça suppose ishow maxime c'est
dommage la haye pays bas mais il perd le
match hyper le macho et sur l'ouverture
et sur les sur les sautes de
concentration aussi un aussi mais
surtout moi je trouve sur sa écoute faut
vraiment que tu convainquent magnus pour
qu'ils reviennent le crilan colle une
petite anna cas quand même ce qu'il
veuille y fait moins le malin quand tu
joues contre du magnus un nîmois en
train de chanter un je vais en faire
vous avez vu le et la finale ckoi de
mystère c'est juste un jeu comme karine
endettés un stage est envoyée là je peux
dire que manu je n'étais pas en forme le
matin était malade y avait une crème pas
possible et pas dormi et il y avait
quand même + 3 + 4 il ay film 2016 il a
joué les dernières c'est ça donc il a
gagné le 2010 est aussi oui donc c'était
la première année où il gagne et
beychevelle
je veux dire la fia n'était vraiment pas
il était malade a donc ça veut dire
qu'il a de la marge
et on se disait d'ailleurs avec peter
que finalement un match comme ça bah
c'était beaucoup plus que le championnat
et gagner un match comme ça comme un jeu
champion du monde mal c'est pour plus de
partie 1
ouais non mais oui d'accord mais c'est
quand même du blitz et tout ça mais il
aime beaucoup plus favori ouais mais les
parties s'enchaînent en plus c'est du
coup quand tu es plus fort tu te dis que
tu glisses sur ta chaise a été et est
apte à glisser ah oui non non c'est bon
allez pardon je pisse sur la chaise j'ai
tendance à vous wes parlons pour le dos
non mais c'est très mauvais pour vous
parler de mes problèmes sinon on n'est
pas confronté
par quoi d'hernie discale qu'est ce qui
t'arrive
non non non non utilisés comme tous les
gens qui adorent alors dit christiane
mal aulas et le clouage la haye a pas vu
un maxime héroïque ça se termine à temps
la tête s'il vient de faire après h3c le
gaz d'environ chaque cours est ici voilà
c'est dommage ton prend 1,3 c'est joli
mais si ça vole à la pâte en échec
et puis ont franchi 6 oui mais à tomber
quand même pas de ma terroristes
tourcoing f1 aura peut-être qu'il a
nommé jean préjugés sur ses cauchemars
tu vois que j'ai dit que je trouve sa
part mme maria a non mais regard non
mais attends mais c'est insupportable
non mais c'est insupportable at et ce
qu'il a fait après dame français si ce
nom mais c'est incroyable c'est hyper
jeunes est de fous j'ai un d'accord mais
paris est repartie en train de danser
non mais c'est pas possible
fais quelque chose non je sais pas
qu'est ce que je faisais appeler magnus
rappelle manu ça c'est ça ça doit
l'énerver
non mais nerveux le coiffe à chaque fois
que tu lui parles dit lui j'ai commenté
le match d'hikaru contrat devait l'on
n'en pouvais plus revient quoi erika
ruiz de gagner un il est donc favori là
il y aurait tout à rognan et à daouda
sow d'arrêt contre eux soit moi soit
lors on espère qu'avec une finale duden
ak je pense que toute assez sa femme a
prêché pas mais il est impressionnant
mon sourire
et justement j'ai tout collé dacca -
aucune chance c'est sûr ne soit ils
croient pas qu'il est chargé par exemple
la norme et à son sourd il est allé
beaucoup trop loin déjà il faut que ça
s'arrête on compte sur notre ami ahmedou
dadou data tu te dire les matches que
j'ai vus la contrecarrer la kiné contre
gries tchouk il a été impressionnant bah
oui notation pour battre des troupes
karekin ça mérite un aspect c'est lé
plus fort un respect non mais vraiment
oui oui là avec naka et maxime je pense
et les quatre plus fort et vainio et ma
news ne joue pas ce tournoi oui mais
j'ai aussi à magnus fin juin après si tu
comptes tous les joueurs etc et juste il
est pas d'arcade plus fort il est juste
le plus fort gain oui ou non il n'est
pas dans la même ligue tant qu est ce
qui fait la ja temps pour répéter les
coups c'est ça ouais ouais mais qu'il
n'en aura la place à un endroit plus à
l'est dans très élégant raffiné il est
insupportable c il est insupportable
hi fi nul entre le temps est fini
olalala aux hybrides et serait rose a
annoncé en avril dernier
non non c'est ta le staff qui a bloqué
non qui l'a pas fait exprès il n'a pas
fait exprès il n'a pas fait exprès d'un
cas moi non non non il n'a pas fait
exprès tu plaisantes bas il n'a pas vu
qu'il épate tient il à penser qu'une
autre partie je crois non il est attendu
au dangereux g37 il peut pas jouer cette
aide à mes fils échec de toute façon
ouais nan t'as les pourparlers à six
secondes sur le coup et un jeu mais je
reste je reste avec toi reparler mais tu
ne me vois pas je ne ris pas rien de
chasse qui hélas le chercher là où il
est question c'est maintenant et pas
content le chat que nike a gagné la
nation j mais vous savez que perçoit été
posée et asie l'équipe est en ville et
ils se parlent pas en reste ils se
détestent tout le monde le sait way to
man de serre et se déteste pas mais
il ya juste champion des dakarois qui
s'entendent bien et au reste jean-claude
il a l'air sympa non ou si j'ai
l'impression et la potion pas de chance
la chose il paraît qu'ils parlent
français en plus c'est vrai qu'il parle
français c'est assez étonnant d'ailleurs
il parle pas mal ça va quoi ils jouent
bien d'ailleurs il a mis là il a mis un
petit un petit coup de progrès là le
champion à table
il a gagné 70 points six mois tu vois là
elle ses coûts dis donc raté 26
extraordinaire ouais c'est un déblocage
montagne s'est passé quoi donc en fait
ils croient rocheman mais il est très du
coup ils étaient venus pour travailler
bordeaux au match
remarquons de khanaqine il était venu un
stage mais savait pas été bon bref y'a
pas été repris après et il est très en
confiance
appelez donc c'est pas mal pour jouer
sur cette ouverture tu vois pour avoir
le champion du monde s'est pas toujours
idéal d'avoir un mec comme ça parce que
il a pas mal l'idée est tous assez
intéressant il un peu trop en confiance
donc illégal temps ça fait les choses un
peu trop vite et parfois il vaut mieux
prendre un peu plus de temps mais être
sûr tu vois de la conclusion que je veux
dire ouais normal n est pas une partie
de tournoi tu vois c'est une partie de
ma le champion du monde on c'est
important on a du temps pour se préparer
on comprend son temps tu voyais c'était
à mon avis c'est un peu pour ça après
c'est pas moi qu'il choisit les seconds
non mais je pense que c'est un peu pour
ça qu'il n'a pas été renouvelée disons
et même prix pour le match doit il a été
pris pour un stage d'avant match mais
pas pour marcher et en tout fin mot si
j'étais de la vie des idées un peu un
peu trop un peu trop confiants on va un
peu trop confiants mais skient pas mal
quand même pour jouer des parties
d'échecs mais là il a des sacrés
résultats mais c'est depuis qu'il a
gagné championnats des états unis j'ai
l'impression que ça lui a fait un déclic
mais si tu dis qu'ils y croient y avant
à fond un oui les croyable mais bon moi
manu aux olympiades réagissent
et parce que toute façon amr avait
annoncé qu'il jouait pas et s'ils jouent
il veut jouer l'équipe max est ce que ça
peut être un objectif pour la norvège je
gagnais les olympiades laurent puisque
tu as tu entendu parler size espère
avoir des jeunes comme le petit tard il
a qui monte tout ça prend du plaisir à
jouer ces olympiades mais ça allait de
même je trouve qu'ils s'impliquent il
s'applique beaucoup et peut-être un peu
trop et danse à lui fait très mal quand
ses coéquipiers évidemment qui joue un
peu moins bien que lui
ouais j'ai vu avec les justement
l'approché sigle à bail avec de north
wind au rythme où on avait un chat en
commun et il commence sa demande est
appelée à pedro évident pourquoi il n'a
pas joué cavalier vaches à la fois ici
et nulle c'est leur produit deux mois il
a envie que l'équipe gagne et il a envie
que tout le monde joue bien je n'ai rien
d'autre à tout le monde moi n'y a plus
de place pour ça et c'est pas par
rapport à lui cirque on est tous nuls
ouais donc il est un peu mais voilà il
joue la coupe d'europe donc je pense
qu'il y avait le choix entre cette
drogue ce qui est vraiment son équipe de
copains à sa fin et et les olympiades
ils payent pas jouer les deux donc il a
préféré privilégier la coupe d'europe
sachant que l'équipe aux olympiades
serait pas accompli parce que mais j'ai
ouï dire que hammer il voulait plus trop
jouer si j non je crois pas c'est ce que
j'ai entendu dire après j'en sais rien
il a gagné la politique ngoc tu vois en
début août
j'étais en temps j'ai discuté lui a pas
si longtemps c'est parce que j'avais
jamais comment progresser les gens
passionnés qui m'ont dit mais après je
ne sais pas non je pensais que l'andorre
paris joue pas mal à parker joue bien là
il est bien plus en plus il a une
période de regain à edouard 2610 donc ça
a bien marché ces derniers temps et
il peut il peut être que très peu
d'énergie et donc la maxima une green
fais pas ta voix sans voix lors on en a
mais là j'en peux plus je n'en peux plus
de cette caméra je vais l'éteindre a
forcé quoi tu vas être maca minutes
notre ami arrivant j'ai consignes orales
ont laissé les têtes des joueurs mais
bon je le pire en appellera de chasse
points communs pour leur dire écoutez
votre compatriote et trop insupportable
non mais il aime bien en plus un haka
jeu c'est un les américains aiment bien
ouais
jordin gaychet 0 moi je suis c'est pas
trop mon truc chez zéro là il ya eu zéro
pose une question
moi j'y connais pas grand chose dont je
suis pas le bon client pour ce nom là le
chat si tu pars sur l'île à 0 sur match
ils vont être à fond ouais mais tu
devrais suis franchement par curiosité
laurent sur twitch tu peux voir en
direct je t'enverrai le lien tata les
parties de l'île à 0 contre les stocks
fischer qui nie tout ça on dirait que
moi ce que je parte à bâle il a zéro il
est un peu dans le même messi impression
c'est ces évaluations en fait il ya des
évaluations vraiment humaine d'accord un
peu comme au dîner c'était poids lourds
daudigny à l'époque m'a encore plus
d'accord écoute je connais pas grand
chose donc je vais d'ailleurs de faire
non mais sérieux en cycle atteint
pourquoi faut prendre ces quatre matches
pas que ça marche mais la fff annonce
qu'il prend un tour à la française alors
attends est ce que max il peut oui bien
sûr a gagné c'est madame sans gêne
oui bien jouer tout rage cette dame s 4
tours age 2 oui j'ai quatre c'est pas
terrible d'amour prend 1,3 qui revient
en dessinant
qu'est-ce qui jouit tout à ça c'est
extraordinaire moi qui ai jamais joué de
bullet de ma vie j'ai joué dix bullet
dans toute ma vie je suis épaté à ses
habitants
c'est incroyable attends je touche
perdant 0 contre c'est pas de cas vite
ok je fais des poires ça c'est sûr mais
en bullet j'ai juste à l'est d'oran
ça part de là trois points de retard
mais ça va aller ça peut aller
attends je vais remettre le chrono elle
joua finale maintenant je la finale dans
les bulles est c'est un comique vaccine
ben écoute c'est peut-être pas une
mauvaise idée si j'ai une petite idée
enfin au lieu de la faire au début qu'on
leur a le temps de dons qu'ils jouent
cette structure ouais j'ai toujours
pensé que ça pouvait être me paul blanc
faut qu'il aille à une laurence allah et
au moins vivre oui faut qu'il revienne à
portée de fusil
ouais non mais il ya une petite chose ça
ou quelle bêtise c'est bizarre tu as
fait ton cavaliers ans et quatre pouces
et un derrière un projet droit ils
montrent leurs ouailles phocéen a poussé
quatre f4 donne au plus haut en deux ans
bull est allé on s'amuse à temps me joue
vite il leur reste une minute chacun a
les joues ils jouent avec leur seconde
de rajouts c'est incroyable et b5
qu'est ce qui n'a pas vu tout reprend
2,6 c'était peut-être un peu too much en
déception est là dans la vie allait
faire un bon énorme qu'il a dit au
prince est un âne on assigne à quai ou 2
et 4 d'accord là c'est qu'on n'a pas
trop le temps de rien il prend toi on a
un qu'on vient de moi
l'offre rencontre plus facile voilà bah
y'en a que deux mois que nous surprenant
attention aux faux
je pensais qu'il ya un an au moins 3 ou
4 124 l'aspect f4 ouais ouais c'est pas
si clair laurent sais pas si tu peux
ça joue un peu au f4 f5 pour france et 7
s est passé lors du day 3 du jeu les
trois des joueurs s'est passé dans
l'automate préféré se faire tout bref tu
fous ils voulaient empêcher tout à fait
chaque jour mon père tour est fixé ça
non mais attends j'ai quatre échelles
eisen la case de 5
oui ça coûtait un pion m bon voilà c'est
les quatre pions ouais mais s'est pas
fait en bus les teams asmat en un coup
de trois c'est dur quand même un nom
c'est dire s'est il a réussi à
stabiliser
ouais mais roanne et cette tour des huit
matchs encore bien croire ces trois
aéroports deuxième pion allez hop on
[Musique]
attend du net tout peut arriver un même
avec eux ah ouais ouais non même avec
eux et au point qu on l'a noyé trop
quatre échecs ok bon eh oui ouais mais
si le bordel le roi est pas si bien à la
position est chaotique où tout peut
arriver le français et oui là c'est un
par un les saucissons roi est un peu mal
maintenant
ah oui mais bon il récupère et rick
perry beaucoup de pure et poussé 50.3
réunion arrive à sauver
et est ce qui va les jouer à l'autre ils
jouiront pareil je pourrai pour faire
sonner la montée des gages à ses
collègues
est-ce qu'en théorie peut les jouer au
foot corpo zela nom pareil c'est pas
beau de faire ça
ces grilles tube qui avait lancé cette
mode c'est moche mais griffu peut
arrêter lui-même parce qu'il a compris
que c'était moche en fait à non ça va
jouer assez horrible là mais ok mais tu
peux pas jouer ça décemment non non il
veut faire du lot si ça va howie fait
savoir ne pas toucher tu vois et il
assume même pas son manque de classe
non mais il faut arriver tu vois moi
j'attends le type a et fumer pour jouer
beaucoup tu vois dans j'attends parfaite
je me rends compte qu'il va fumer et je
veux encore le petit coussin j'assume le
truc tu vois je n'en suis pas fier mais
quand même âge dans le chat du respect
respect pour les joueurs
sinon j'ai adopté de bonnes intentions
une mère si dunkerque attention
attention je peux tu es un peu
supporters on peut ici dire les choses
avec avec politesse un chèque et ça
c'est un manque d'élégance mais bon oui
mais bon on peut le dire avec des mots
voilà ce n'est pas un comportement qu'on
peut atteindre le joueur de ce niveau
c'est bien dit c'est bien dit il
bon après je te préviens que great
schouppe lui il aurait joué pendant cinq
ans bon maintenant grisou qui l'a fait
pire il a fait pire mais il assumer à
fond c'est à dire qu'il faisait pas
semblant
c'est bien le vit le faisait vraiment et
il le faisait de manière très très
ouvert toi je pensais le mieux mais
l'heure n'était pas fier mais je vais
parler avec vlad après le match et ils
ont été patients mais ils avaient
vraiment envie de gagner mais c'est
typique du cioc non mais oui enfin
mais bon il a su me dit ouais c'est pas
classe mais ils avaient vraiment envie
de gagner ce soir et donc qui fut m les
chansons côté ça raconte maxime d'air
mais il a des chances là ou pas c'est
mes yeux non je pense que c'est chaud
pour tout le monde dans cette position
ouais on peut faire prendre des cartons
est ce que les bonnes à une chance je
pense que les bonnes à +2 contre maxime
un pardon contre maxime il y aurait plus
de chances que contre nadal
parce qu'il a quand même yann historique
tellement peur que par la veille les
sept là non il est foutu
ouais ah non elle tire fait sa tête de l
attention
pas tant que ça à l qu'ailleurs f5
transforme avec rouen g2 ils essayent
c'est fini on la sait quoi 4,4 à
plusieurs voilà ce qu'il aurait dû faire
depuis le départ batibois il est préparé
sur tout mais peut-être aussi le fait
qu'il est complètement raté ces
olympiades ça s'arrange s'adonneront le
match plus important pour naka que pour
maxime
ouf ça prend l'eau il ya quand même
beaucoup de défaites de ce type là andy
coup un ouais mais c'est un peu chiant à
jouer ça pour pour les noirs d'ailleurs
si on avait gagné une partie contre way
back a perdu cette partie et manuscrits
c'est vrai mais d'autres humains
confirmés comme d'hab' 1 c'est le cas
mais genre ça peut ça peut être
dangereux quoi faire gaffe m oui bien
sûr bah d'ailleurs est moins bien alors
voilà
ces finales là sont très mauvaises pour
les rhénans geslin tomber aux tours
servent même la fia toutes composées de
hockey lah les cairotes sont nombreux en
fuite avec vous deux j'espère qu'on aura
quand même réussi à faire gagner un
petit peu d'argent aux gens mardi parce
qu'on nous avait posé la question
ce que n'a qu'à était à 1,50 pour le
match d'accord ouais mais même maxime
disais que c'était pas vu l'historique
et qu'il était bon sur internet et tout
ça c'est pas une belle cote ce que je
dis aux gens ici donc j'espère que marié
contre maxime comment vous ait fait
gagner un peu d'argent avec l'info qu'on
a lâché parce qu'à 50 ça me paraissait
un peu gonflés d'assurance tu vois tu es
content quoi qu'il arrive moi ça
m'arrive de faire comme ça oui dommage
tu vois je mets un peu de trucs sur le
mec j'ai pas envie qu'il soit mais au
moins un mois et un peu d'argent tu vois
en conversation et mettez le mieux tpr
en retard aussi non pas tant que ça non
non j'aime bien la dame ajoute un peu
al'inverse les regards vides et repliée
trop il m'énerve pietro correct ouais
mais trop lisse dans cette interview il
est trop lent mais il est trop parfait
en fait moi je pense que lui si tu vas
fumée il faut pas tempo quoi ouais il
est trop parfait ya trop de temps le
sourire est trop beau perdant il est
trop il n'y a pas assez de défauts
gestion des choses il m'énerve
en fait mais non non mais tu vois il n'a
pas vraiment plu il n'a jamais cassé une
raquette tu vas d'énervement moi je
préfère mcenroe quoi john mcenroe
j'adore quoi il s'est d'ailleurs mis la
suite les arbitres oui à bientôt hors
norme et tu vois il a fait un truc
c'était sans regarder quoi moi j'ai pas
riche au co djoko arrêt djoko éléments
documents locaux il ya quelque chose
mais bon j'aime beaucoup rothlach aussi
les rodgeur il a germé tu vois si déjà
énervé au delà en revanche je trouve que
nacaso nakamura nadal c'est une bonne
source d'inspiration pour en tant que
compétiteur c'est pas mal way est non
csii ben je sens qu'il ya une énergie
qui était puissante pas extra mille îles
a tourné en rond pendant des heures un
vide et horrible soit sport par anne on
attend il fait surgir le bouton il sait
quoi non mais bon tu mènes 2 qui mène de
cinq points t'as pas besoin de ça ouais
c'est moche non mais tu as y avait un ou
deux points d'écart je comprends mais
après il fait 3 fois même position je
crois non non non non non non ils
tournent plus jeune ranger servait
beaucoup à d'accord j'ai pas l'harmattan
puissiez super finale on le dirait
contre rogers mais c'est juste super pop
voilà comme tous les tous les français à
mazet maximum ils sont tous celui tonton
femme attend femmes à fond ouais ils
sont tous à fond tu vois là rodgeur
rodgeur qu'elle déjà moi non mais oui
oui c'est bien évidemment il jouit parmi
5000 n'y a pas de j'espère que c'est toi
qui avait gagné le tour dans la tennis
échec
ouais en finalement emmanuel mazet et
battu mazet qui a joué si tu veux de la
définition de petits bras il a donné
dans cette finale aussi à queue au
tennis il est quand même
cerci je fais six heures c'est normal
quoi
et donc j'ai réussi à mener 13 12 dans
le xiii rose même je venais dans le tie
break et j'ai gagné en échec à 3,4 et il
est très apprécié des ouais bah c'est
mon ami seb donc je peux tu vois mais il
a joué moi entrer il a joué tellement
petit bras au tennis était incroyable
quand ça fait peur de la flore du titre
ouais enfin qui sur les échecs et donc
c'est sympa ce témoin mais du coup
magnus tu penses il pourrait être favori
de cette compétition vont pas très fort
au tennis alors il est bon il est au
creux de charge sont ils trop
fantaisistes besoin qu'ils fassent des
progrès ne tuerez call classement au
tennis moi je dois jouer la 30e 32e quoi
à mon père il aurait été pas mal alors
est maso il joue il joue 15,2 la soirée
classement j'ai aucune chance contre
attaque une chance soit 15,2 contre le
mépris non mais si je dors mal mais si
sa 6e oui c'est sûr ouais t'as aucune
chance normalement ouais ouais mais la
pression du titre voix ouais la pression
des titres bon donc là ouais bon ici
parce que rien donc là c'est toujours
cinq points d'avancé ça il reste plus
qu'un câble je vais dire qu'on met une
reste de temps à rs 13 minutes
c'est quasiment mathématiquement pas
faisable parce que na canada quel parti
qui veut gagner il faut avec cette
cadence il faut deux minutes trente
trois minutes un ouais mais mon maxi
l'hyper vraiment que sur les partis qui
l'a bien pays perd sur des cadeaux en
fait et sur les mauvais choix de votre
choix de partir je persiste et signe je
sais pas comment on peut expliquer ces
cadeaux parce que c'est joli conte n'a
cassé c'est toujours ce scénario de
cadeaux qui arrive à andré c'est une
force aussi de faire des sauts pourquoi
il marque on tente quoi ils gagnent
jamais so nice est vrai déjà vu café tu
as déjà vu va être un truc employés tu
as déjà vu rater une tactique simple
jamais même magnus ça lui arrive de
temps en temps bien sûr beaucoup plus
souvent à il peut beaucoup plus de
choses
je rappelle une partie de garou existait
mais là il fait jamais une gaffe il
concentré tout le temps il et c'est pour
ça qu'il est je pense qu'il est beaucoup
moins fort que les autres mais il a des
qualités différentes qui font qu'ils
sont moins sympa à regarder tu vois mais
comme nacala en vite
il donne rien il a joué des jeux c'est à
l'époque et je veux y jouer toute la
nuit et ambitieux tutelle mais un petit
peu fois j'espère pour les mets
non mais je suis arrivé peut-être c'est
de faire dame 1 8 hours et 8 maxime
ouais les llorach watch est non tu vas
pas bien les biens rares et madame 6-3
j'ai vu mais bon tu cette nuit
assaillent apris prisés et puis là il va
faire tomber trois tours b says karachi
ah ouais mais parce que parce que
maintenant il ya plus inquiet car 11
minutes et que et que le match est gagné
pour naka mais je pense qu'il va gagner
cette compétition très facilement au
final 1 je crois aussi
je crois qu'il est mis 28 2 au 1er tour
à wigan c'est pas ça tu parles d'un ces
îlots réaliser et qu'elle n'est ce pas
comme nous tu joues pas toi je dis bah
non qualifié pour jouer trois heures
comme toi tu voyais finir à 27,3 tu vois
tu parles d'un plaisir c'est un truc qui
me réjouit quoi donc c'est vrai que ces
trucs là de jouer en lice en bullet
ouais ça peut être une torture un brief
avec une fille aussi aurait pu leur
mettez je pense à la cahc mois il a bien
stylé ya pas peur mais peut-être ce doux
dingue je pense duda peu gêné je pense
que doivent être sot de façon illégale
pacifié l'écologie c'est impossible
c'est même pas la peine
mais d'houdain non plus 12 ha il a
dominé en tactique great chouquer faut
aussi dommage c'est ce qui arrive à
londres assailli chaud ou laquelle
espace pas terrible à part ça doit
s'arrêter avec et c3 effet comme ça
quand je pense à pas ça n'a aucun
intérêt maintenant c'est cruel way et
puis en plus stressé que le score
gonflait c'est cruel pour maxime oui
d'appareils sa vendent pas et ça ne pas
une idée du mac en fait est beaucoup
plus tendue que ça c'était quand même
chaud pas jeter à saint servan
c'était chaud non merci ça fait genre au
tennis a fait un truc où tu as perdu 7,6
très chaud 6-3 quoi ça ferait ce score
l'arbre parce qu'il y avait neuf partout
finalement ouais il a perdu 4,4 d'oran
et sagna pas ça
cette pâle score et en plus cette
palmeraie non plus arrêté après anglet
dommage dommage non mais ça reflète pas
le match franchement le score ne reflète
plus tu vas +4 cela refléterait +3 +4
pas plus oui des records a aidé à me
prendre et ce avec des jouets allez faut
qu'il en gagne c'est incroyable de
gagner le match et quand même
insupportable bras qui se passe dans la
maxima 8 cependant que farid quit à il
n'a pas le droit
ouais je me doute oui sinon ça serait
déjà eu il ya une petite chance que
manucho face mais je pars' c'est un cas
qui ne peut pas arriver tu vois ni pluie
ni com - brest à minutes de la fin je
pense que c'est un truc de fou de corps
posés il peut faire aux red wings mais
regarde ce qui lui fait bon après je
veux dire que j'avais vu le feu prendre
les 3 mai mais il est quand même
il est beaucoup il faut qu'il faut
qu'ils la gagnent vraiment pour pas que
ce soit trop sévère la lila k terminaux
dit oui fans alors il peut encore deux
ou trois noms mais elle a pris 10 01
moment tu auras plus 3 + 0 10 euros ça
fait mal quand même pas 10 euros
et ça se battait au moins dans les
partis ou non pas trop en fait massacre
bassac et dhaka il est dur mais trop
grande différence de niveau
qui sait qu'il y avait goûté nord qui
est fait quatre points je crois
contrebas news ouais manu ça y est c'est
fait un très mauvais match après c'était
oui ça c'est drôle d'ailleurs sur 12
étaient contents et l'autre d'aider
goûtez y avait eu 19,4 et pour celui qui
voit là je vous rappelle j'avais vu les
interviews d'après match où tu peux pas
deviner il ya aucun monde tu devenu le
score tu penses que magnus a perdu 12-10
quelque chose comme ça vous aurez à
trois points de plus donc celle là ça va
être bien de la gagne et quand même un
ouais mais il va pas abandonner il va
laisser tourner la pendule au maximum
quand même on va pouvoir y a six points
d'écart il ya six minutes
oui
mais bon ça montre aussi qu'il avait pas
match gagné avant d'avancer 1,6 pensée
brad thorn o c'est pour ça qu'il est
aussi content d'ailleurs et qui se
dandine en temps parce que contre louis
fanny faisait pas autant enfin à quoi
que il va il n'y a pas de pattes comme
celle là car bullet non j'étais passé
telle misère et demi qui compte 10 0
c'était la camorra ou iphone ouais non
je sais pas où c'était des miséreux nuit
mais il avait battu car c'est non oui où
il avait battu ambühl est aussi vrai ou
peut-être que l'enquêté remonte à la fin
tu sais quoi
peut-être que magnus mener quelque chose
comme 5 3 et qu'il est perdu et 2,3
dernière mais parce que j'avais match
est terminé et qu'il avait un peu
relâché la pression
il a déjà des problèmes parfois nakamura
il se prend des réflexions on devait
partir à cause de son comportement
ouais d'aller se prend d'affection de
bon après les autres joueurs sont
habitués et les joueurs du top c'est là
qu'ils jouent quasiment toujours les
mêmes joueurs mais je sais que c'est
déjà une belle il faut dire c'est
spécial s'était assis en face de lui qui
fait ça toute la partie takam envie de
l'ancolie mer en plus ça se passe mal
enfin tu te vois
la maxime ils le voient pas d'un cas moi
oui le voit enfin où ils pourraient le
voir mais je pense pas qu'il semblait
pas le regarder ça serait bizarre et a
perdu un client l'a tout de suite dans
cette zone fun encore néanmoins
reconnaître ça il est acté il a été très
consistant cette bonne nouvelle
y a pas lâché un roman où il disait
d'eux tu vois on a pensé que c'était une
mauvaise décision pour lui finalement
m&g pas évidemment il nous a director
vraiment bizarre que maxime est pas
réussi à régler ses problèmes dans la
green fait quand même 1 ce qui la
connaît bien dans chacune fait sinon tu
vois il faut lui et c'est peut-être tu
vois tu laisses je pense 15 minutes avec
on en dit peut-être qu'il ya plus de
chance qui y règne mais là tu vois comme
salle aveugle entre deux blitz
c'est pas comme ça se passait bien avec
les blancs tu vois tu as des soucis à
régler en fait ils voient ce n'est pas
évident mais un énorme c'est pas facile
c'est là qu'il se retrouve à défendre ça
donc l'aller c'est quoi elle pousse et
501 oreillette ou bien en gagner pas
mais pays là à il est dû rater sur le
dangereux criminel ou ses cinq attaques
de pions un terminal la repasse à +6 6
demande quel joueur le plus fair-play
roux niveau que tu connaisses à une
méthode ruiz du couvent est maxime il
est très fair play back ci après jour
guy bizarrement et la de bobo paire de
running la musique hyper jamais aussi
donc
cisco annonce
moi je trouve les vols non je pense pas
les bonnes et très beau baignant les
bonnes quantités bytes suis dans le
remarque antique anti père et où caser
il a fait une ultime peu à peu mauvaise
il est - il est moins présente elle est
très très beau gagnants les pubs c'est
très désagréable de personnes et non les
veaux n'est pas du tout et pas du tout
reperdu viendra chercher en bref oui
bien sûr - ouais bah oui ça change une
chambre et yaggeuses et un truc au qatar
et et c'était le champion de beats voir
vraiment là j'avais mal joué pour le
coup et je jouais du type je suis plus
doublé quoi tu vois je faisais le tour
du globe couette et ils disaient ils
émanent des sucettes son adversaire j'ai
entendu il a mis 26 heures pour arriver
ici
donc tu peux leur demander maintenant
comment
il voit en gros il est suggéré de
demander à mes adversaires comment
s'était passée un voyage à ce qui t as
well as they come pourquoi tu trouves ça
fait 20 ans que je le connais il vient
me voir pour me dire ça tu vois tu vas
voir tu vois si prenez les défaites avec
le sourire tu vois bon encore passe mais
je sais qu'il y en ait encore gagné donc
voilà donc ces délais je dirais maxime
dillies ding magnus fair play ou fair
play mais tu folie il vous faut lui et
ses deux heures quoi il n'est pas fair
play tout de suite après les très fair
play mais il faut lui laisser le temps
de digérer structure deux heures ou deux
jours par après il est fair-play tu vois
il va féliciter la personne et tout ça
mais il a il a du mal à sur le coup moi
dans ce fair-play tu vois voici après
deux jeux 6-2 heures plus tard il dit
que son adversaire amérique et tout ça
toi il a juste besoin de d'encaisser la
défaite
du coup on parle de lui de la grotte
dans un an ou deux ans un feu est un
jour non mais il pourrait pas si mal et
tu vois c'était pas sûr je sentais que
c'est pas son sujet de discussion favori
qu'est ce que je peux comprendre et déjà
un truc assez marrant parce que je
voyais ça partie kong et celle qui a
perdu la vie ce qu'hardy n'ait pas
regarder ça et donc je fais commencent à
défiler pour voir ce qu'ils avaient raté
tu vois alors ton décalé et bitumes et
un coup de plus dans cette partie et tu
es viré au rouge arrête de la regarder
tu m'as convaincu et je ressentais
vraiment rigolé par les spéciales a
glissé spéciale il est sur twitter tu
vois il essaye toujours de ouais mais
c'est pas d'enfant quand même non c'est
pas méchant il est icode sur twitter tu
vois il est un peu moi je trouve assez
agacé bon assez arrogant mais je pense
pas mais ça fait parler c'est bien
ouais
bah oui il ya beaucoup d'humour mais je
voudrais que ce soit méchant je pensais
plus du chambrage un peu lourd mais je
pense pas que ce soit méchant à
proprement dire non moi je sais pas
assez maintenance et c'est maxime qui
joue la montre c'est l' écoute c'est
ainsi et c'est fini je crois que ses
avants qui ont l'art et non c'est fini
+8 je suis toit dur c'est beaucoup hein
ouais c'est beaucoup laurent c'est moche
ouais c'est une vérité le bruit lâcher
prise car le match était perdu
donc bon mot - 4 - 8 août il ya eu match
jusqu'à jusqu'à 9 9 9 9 et c'est là que
ça a tourné
ouais ouais c'est là sa tombe est vrai
dans ces écoutes ce que tu as wihr ya
perdu beaucoup à ce jour là il a
commencé à perdre et à perte de vue des
parties assez rapidement donc trop de
cadeaux cette italienne quand même qui a
été un fiasco intégral sur le match
semblait match je pense qu'il finit un
couac italienne à - 3 - 4
voilà c'est dommage ça joue sur ça je
pense la grogne s'est bien tenue quand
même mieux au départ qu'à la femme et ça
c'est bienvenu nous voilà un peu trop de
wes hesco utilisés je pense un peu trop
de cadeaux d ouverture et une ouverture
il est blanc qui marchent pas bien je
vois les prénoms en fait on sort du
match on n'a pas l'impression de
nakamura est plus fort non mais plus
plus consistants une consistance plus
stable
pas plus fort mais plus consistant
n'hésitez pas à george en profitent
avant on va voir je sais pas si rare un
maximum d'interviews pas l'aimer était
un petit coeur sur la chaîne pour la
suivre 100 points comme il faut la
suivre à tout le moins je sais pas si tu
suis la chaîne chez ascom fr non non je
vais faire je vous ai très motivé et je
vais voir les prochains matchs et courir
je regarderai duda donné à duda sofinan
tu va regarder la vidéo
moi je faisais pas après ça c'est
important c'est tout ça mais je vous
aimez cette intrigue finalement le match
quand même douze hommes intègres à 12
heures
m égal ou d'argent l'intéressant c'est à
nouveau jouer car tu vois mais tu sais
pas trop il est vachement doux et ça
c'est clair
tu sais pas quel point jusqu'où il peut
aller je pense qu'il peut aller assez
haut mais je connais pas assez encore tu
vois pour juger donc j'ai envie de me
faire une idée plus claire toi saut je
sais je sais quel match qui va faire ma
caméra je sais quel match il va faire un
renard il va pas me surprendrait tu vois
les autres joueurs je les vois mal me
surprendre mais duda je sais pas je
passais longtemps que je vois c'est
l'intérêt aussi du truc tu vois mais je
pense ne pas être le fait qu'il ait fait
un aussi bon résultat en speechless vu
le format est vu vu tout ce qu'on en a
dit à mon avis ça montre quand même un
gros talent oui bien sûr parce que tenir
ces mecs là sur un match de trois heures
et demie surtout que c'est pas de la
chanson truc quand tu gagnes un match
mal de mecs fait en mauvaise forme mais
quand on gagne deux coup sur coup
ouais mais ça veut pas tu vois caruana
par exemple les nuls dans ces trucs par
rapport à son niveau en particulier
d'amélie mauvais en bits en général et
bears merci c'est gentil les
commentaires ne soit nommé
non mais sczesny les gens terre alors on
s'est même genre je vous remercie pour
tous les commentaires gentil ça fait
plaisir toujours et à bientôt pour ceux
qui s'en vont c'est pas nous je sais pas
chanter un débrief on peut faire des
briques vraiment pour proposer ça me
fait plaisir je vois pas en meublé ou
être au bout d'à et quand même la grosse
attraction du tournoi
d'habitude c'est magnus à demi-nus donc
duda donc c'est sympa quand même
est ce que est ce que si duda a gagné un
truc magnus aura envie de faire un match
exhibition contre 12 à pour toi pour une
montrer qui était le patron
c'est ce genre de choses ça peut leur
patron ont cessé le bosquet mois merci
ici tu as décidé à gagner ce point comme
j'aime pas dire tout ça est meilleur que
manu tu as toujours pensé que manu c'est
vrai mais ce que ça peu le show fait en
dix ans à un nouveau mec c'est un
nouveau challenge talent sans cela dans
le sens où j'ai jamais battu quoi ouais
non mais bon
il a battu à toulouse a déjà en partie
longue et j'agis les commentaires que je
peux concentrer sur ce côté gecov par un
chat bondi de 10,1 fois par ailleurs et
non je pense que non il a appris en
sérère tu vois après il joue pas les
trucs sur chaque point comme voilà on a
plus d'infos que moi sur les raisons
pour lesquelles jouent pas mais je pense
que le truc il aime beaucoup en fait ces
trucs là en fait je crois qu'il aime
beaucoup et je pense qu'il sait juste
pas mis d'accord est pas comme c'est
justement ça le problème
mais moi de ce que j'ai entendu de c est
toujours là moi je suis là je suis
acheté tout celle de ce que j'ai entendu
mois du retour de c2c de ces matches qui
joue et c'est griffen tu vois enfin il a
tissé jamais plaint de ses matches sur
16 pas comme toi il s'amuse beaucoup
quand il joue ses matches et pour lui
c'est un critère quand même qui est très
important donc donc c'est pas ça le
c'est pas le format ou le problème voilà
après il n'a pas trouvé d'accord comme
d'autres joueurs de tennis se trouvent
pas d accord avec des tournois tu vois
j'espère qu'on retrouvera un accord
l'année prochaine pour la voir quoi
voilà c'est ça ce qui manque quand même
à la compétition c'est évident que quand
il ya un grand chef tour par exemple
avec manu tous en magnus
enfin je suis pas complètement neutre
dans cette histoire mais il me semble
qu'on voit la différence même tournoi
avec manu tous en magnus
c'est quand même délicat oui c'est sûr
si l'attraction vraiment su comment
faire donc mais il ya duda mais à duda
qui est marrant et est là et on va voir
s'il ya qu'à moi non mais là il a vu la
sienne finale n'a qu'à duda c'est sûr
que ce sera ok ça vous fera pas un haka
magnus parce que t'as pas un but mais ce
sera quand même un match qui donne
vraiment envie de voir déjà duda
d'audace on a envie de voir ses vraies
oppositions si on a envie de voir
comment duda se se comportent compte
remettre aux normes comme comme sow est
vraiment et là qui va faire sa
prestation tu vois on sait ce qui va
faire aller vite heures après le
résultat dépend vraiment de duda et de
sa capacité à le déstabiliser
c'est ouvert après le deuxième la
deuxième demi finale
l'armée n'a karajan franchement les mecs
ça sera comme en a évidemment aux 50 tu
peux mettre ta maison fortement misé
votre appartement
arenas est sûre c'est ça sera pas ça
quand ça sera un vin mais même un vent
tu peux y allèrent en est rien elle voit
pas dans le monde les vannes gagne le
match en fait non en fait je pense que
la cote ces genres 1,05 ou un 10-1
vraiment je peux je fais pas les côtoie
j'ai l'impression ces deux je peux je ne
vois pas ça arrive et non je peux voir
pareil je suis comme toi tu vas pas
enfin en fait même si dans un scénario
de rêve ils arrivent à égalité en début
du bullet je le vois pas tenir en fan je
le vois m'apprendre 6,7 points bull est
quoi oui et même avant rm et sami sur
quel site je sais pas sur quel site ça
les gens tu n'écris marathon de bêtes
marathon de bateaux y dont j'avais déjà
vu pour moi c'est un petit peu interdit
doit miser sur les cibles la vandoise il
a pourtant assuré sitruk des noix et sur
l'échec face est complètement interdit
d'ailleurs
ouais c'est complètement interne soit
sur n'importe quel site on regarde pas
le droit toi ouais non j'ai pas droit
ouais mais par exemple rien toi parents
que si tu vas à parier sur le premier
coup des parties de magnus ou quoi
matches championnat du monde de taille
les infos ouais bah c'est ce que faisait
vraiment c'est ce qu'a raconté
voilà lisez le bouquet casse pas rentrer
et à compter que joueur un joueur
faisait ça c'est sûrement faisait ça
mais il pensait pas à mal
l'empathie dieu le le secondaire on
pensait pas mal en fait
c'est un moyen pour lui de gagner un peu
d'argent facilement tu vois et en fait
qu'à sa tête
oui non mais tu peux pas ta pâte à pas
loin d'aider que mais bon t'as loin de
paris et sur les autres sports par
contre et surtout elle m'a donné des
conseils aux futurs par ailleurs mais on
n'a pas du tout en fait on a parlé vous
parlez ans en ont parlé juste de ça
comme ça mais non mais non mais non à
paris où l'on parlait juste de conseils
du mal à l'or noir est juste de
pronostic pour le pour le pour le pour
le blitz sur facebook com et c'est vrai
que le seul qui peut embêter nakamura
ces 12 heures moi je suis d'accord avec
toi je pense que le seul qui peut le
clip où il bouscule et non dans le monde
dans ce qu'ils peuvent le bousculer en
général tapote à mike weiss -17 1 maxime
taghrid shoots avant ta carte scène
évidemment et dak lak et acariâtre
mais tous les autres je pense à un
massacre sur 10 ligne riding gordini
était pas bon en blitz au qatar là quand
on a fait le stage baissé il ya 2 3 ans
id rend pas un talent extraordinaire
après il a certainement fait des progrès
mais il vient vous pas trop des beats
mais il n'a pas lu il n'ya pas le genre
je pense je le vois pas en train de
jouer sur internet sur troubles mais
digne pour être point de voir des
guérillas fait des propos à savoir un
média elle a perdu quinze lemon way
ailleurs on est encore loin
anon des t bonds et oui et non c'est
fini c'est fini mais à l'époque à mon
avis il aurait pu faire mal hein c'est
vrai non je vois pas d'autres les autres
sont probablement beaucoup trop d'accord
non car wallace même pas la peine car
les ponts ou men et pau il ya peu est
stable n'est pas qu'on laisse partir
l'armée n'est pas en plus j'avais vécu
un cauchemar quand on avait commenté
on avait commenté
née pocard jaeckin et à commencer par 9
0 karine audio
ouais tu m'as saxe avait été et n'est
pas là contre gries choo qu'il avait
oscillé pas mal joué mais il est quand
même en dessous de tout ça crame nika
des beaux réflexes mais je crois que il
peut pas vraiment fort les chroniques
peut être très dangereux s'ils jouent
quelques joueurs parce que je suis allé
faire match d'entraînement avec magnus
avant vers leur 2015 et s'en sortent et
j'étais étonné par le score vraiment
c'était que sur vingt artistes et +4
pour la news sur l'aspect norme c'est
pas énorme du tout donc assez et tu vois
donc qu'il faut qu'il se passe un
excellent joueur de beats cramer lecture
avec des bons réflexes soit il peut
jouer des coudes vraiment les hommes fmh
les cas sport qui était quand même grave
c'était fou donc voilà donc ça prouve
maintenant il a un peu il faut qu'il
s'entraîne tu vois mais il va pas le
faire a priori vlad a priori vlad
évidemment mais vlad est tellement hors
concours
elle est tellement encore au dessus de
tout ça si tu veux que ça sera un
challenge pour magnus coup après font
vraiment c'est vous confronter si tu
veux au meilleur quoi n'était bon qu'à
500 rigoler à l'époque ulad j'ai pas
prêt à parler d'autres végétaux et manu
si paris il parle du coup une origine
ils parlent tous anglais
ouais il parle très bien mais en fait
magnus avec q quand il avait 4 ans à ses
parents vécu en belgique francophone
pendant pas loin d'une année choix est
donc maintenue c'est à ces pays tu vois
il avait 4 50 voix et donc il est
incompris il comprend le pôle france est
vraiment c'est étonnant et on en rit
capte des mots et dans les conversations
et la lumière et il te surveille quoi
ouais tu vois il a vu par exemple de
johnny est mort johnny est mort pendant
le stage et on était en stage à ce point
elvis est mort je sais quand tu seat loi
et donc et je vais passer une chanson tu
vois je vais montrer du doigt une
chanson pour qu'ils essayent de voir pas
tu vois les envies un machin et il a
essayé de comprendre les paroles et au
bout d'un moment il est arrivé il a
compris ainsi à comprendre de quoi ça
parlait donc tu vois il arrive à
comprendre - des paroles qui sont prêts
évidente et il est écouté plusieurs fois
ou dormant il l'a compris de quoi ça
parle et de quoi il parle que français
bah écoute l'orangé pas j'ai pas de
nouvelles je pense pas qu'on prenne
maximum d'interviews derrière en plus il
doit être un peu vert ouais ouais donc
on va on va laisser ça comme il est
adhérent maxime c'est ça ouais j'essaie
de regarder le machin est bon joakim
écrite par les sages ouais mais ce qu'on
va vraiment d'un autre côté ouais moi je
dis on m'a pas écrit machin geste
l'achat de attend
attends je suis en train de le réécrire
un bond à 30 ans je suis j'ai écrit
surtout qu'on galère un peu pour a
yockey attend chez pas là à perrine of
my life as we go to french this kind of
donc je te laisse avec lui là où on fait
comment malahat ans comment récupérer du
coup way
on attend de petites et grandes
attends pas su me battant ils vont
battant faut attendre un petit peu
du coup je te garde encore une petite
minute laurent ou deux bien sûr avec
plaisir je regarde side c'est pas
évident en fait ce que tu veux on doit
de choper sur le truc c'est pas facile
je vais essayer de remettre son image on
lui pose quoique enfin jeu du coup je
pourrais pas tenir en même temps que
maxime je pose comme question du coup je
lui demande si c'est pas trempé laisse
ou à faire un fou je m'ennuie bas oppose
sur la stratégie de match j'en sais rien
du doigt sur le truc c'était un peu
qu'est-ce qu'il est prévu avant l'heure
avant le match qu'est ce qui s'est mal
passé son intelligence et rieur voix
week-end mais bon tant de qualités sa
stratégie grand match parce qu'il avait
quelque chose d'écrit
pourquoi il s'est entêté à jouer
italienne qui avait pas l'air de bien
marcher
qu'est-ce qui va penser de ces bonnes
feuilles fin juin sous le nom plus quoi
ça que je veux dire il a pensé tout en
mâchant général ou quoi ouais non mais
vous mais je crois surtout après ouais
non mais c'est apparu de paris qui a
perdu ce non plus tu vois en lui disant
tu as fait des choix de merde avec tan
italienne ou quoi et tu vois surtout
qu'on est mal placé pour aller dire
faire le mal a pas l'impression qu'ils
aient mois forte voix c'est qu'à un
moment il ya toi tu peux lui dire notre
sentiment c'est qu'on n'a pas
l'impression qu'il est moins fort on va
passer d'un pression là qu'on n'arrivait
pas la tête sous l'eau oui bah déjà si
tu dis qu'il est pas moins fort tu veux
pas te faudrait plutôt plus ouais non
c'est sûr non mes juges aiment pas trop
interview les mecs quand ils perdent et
tout ce que je déteste comme interview
quand je perds en fait on me parle
wen ont manqué le coup c'est pour ça que
je trouve beau joueur maxime ça c'est
vrai qu'il a il ya ce côté là où tu vois
il en fait quand tu perds tu vois pas
trop a dit dans la maille souris et tout
quoi ça va c'est juste que je sais que
moi je suis insupportable à sa place
j'aurais qu'un rêve c'est d'éteindre
l'ordinateur
une pareille pendant une heure où ben
moi aussi ouvrir une petite bière ou un
truc comme ça au report hyper en fait tu
as l'impression que tu vas tu vois tu
dis super tu vas le voir et tout ça va
tu vas audoise humeur a fait pas du tout
tant mieux
ouais alors vas-y atteint 22 coûteux
il arrive pas alors je sais pas je suis
en train d'écrire il m'écrit mais
personne qui m'écrit je sais pas si
jamais évident de récupérer les gens
après c'est vrai qu'ils sont sur lui
sert américain il faut des interviews
d'une demi heure fut pas ce qu'ils
foutent faisait interview très longue en
fait moins d'argent avec maxime on
dirait c'est trois quatre minutes tu vas
faire un fou je me demande comment c'est
passé un accord il avait gagné le jeu
vidéo sur le alors je filme damas
laurent je te laisse pas toujours
salut maxime salut ça va la forme ça va
ça va un peu un peu fatigué évidemment
pas assez déçu évidemment de de comment
j'ai joué en fin de match mais bon je
peux tu peux dire qu'on est déçu on est
déçu aussi hein parce qu'on n'a pas
l'impression que c'était moins fort que
lui ouais alors ça c'était vrai dans la
première partie du match après ça m'a
coûté pas mal d'énergie je pense et je
vais je n'avais plus assez d'énergie
dans la deuxième partie de match et
c'est ce que je pense et puis s'est mis
à mieux jouer aussi à toi de toi qui
aime bien le tennis on vire tout à fait
un peu tout à fait des fautes directes
non surtout c'est c'était pas mal de
d'erreur un peu web après lui aussi donc
en première partie de match c'est vrai
que c'était beaucoup d'erreurs
réciproque assez peu de partis qui
justement était vraiment convaincante du
début à la fin
et puis après oui je crois que j'ai tenu
à peu près un peu plus de 15 partis
comme ça à ce rythme et puis après c'est
vrai que à la fois il a passé
l'accélérateur et puis moi j'ai pas
réussi à continuer à déposer almex d'or
noir sous pression il est des gaffes
ferme afin qu'ils étaient un peu dommage
mais après c'était peut-être question de
motivation peut-être un peu lâche ambühl
est ce qu'on a pensé que c'était donner
vraiment dur quoi non mais en fait ça
allait encore enfin bouger c'est bien
encore d'être compétitif et puis un
moment j'ai fait une mauvaise série
et oui j'ai tâché vers la fin surtout
après avoir encaissé une pièce un tour
française oui une partie alors j'avais
de plus en plus voilà mon là c'est
peut-être la goutte d'eau et du coup on
avait joué avec laurent parce qu on
commentait on était avec laurent pour
commencer ce match et en fait on s'est
posé pas mal de questions pourquoi tu a
insisté dans l'italienne en fait est ce
qu'il y avait une raison tapas est ce
que t'as pas pensé faire passer que tu
allais italie turquie vers la berlinoise
vers la finale oui j'aurais peut-être pu
le faire beaucoup plus tôt mais
j'étais un peu par inertie j'aime bien
la position pour une raison que j'ignore
et donc je vais patiner et ouais ouais
parce que c'était c'est un peu une
revanche dans la green fall s'arrête là
bien au début de match ça se passait
bien qu'on était content enfin ça
c'était cool ça oui
après c'est un peu risqué est forcément
de continuer cette ligne est donc bon à
la fin j'ai fini par le payer aussi
ouais mais bon c'est vrai donc tu dit un
peu craqué physiquement est ce que tu
disais mentalement fin ou les deux on
mélange tout est bon mais du coup ça
fait trois matches que je commande de
toi contre hikaru pour le moment
difficile qu'est ce qu'on fait pour le
gagner la prochaine fois est ce que on
va on fait on fait du voodoo on commence
va tient l'étal est une plante pour la
prochaine fois à le plan c'est que je
joue milieu du début à la fin à près de
toute façon c'est clair que hikaru c'est
à peu près si on excepte magnus et c'est
un peu la terreur de de ce type de
format donc c'est aussi normal après
j'étais content de moi justement de
réussir à garder le match vraiment
closes pendant un long moment et puis
après oui c'est vrai que j'aurais aimé
vraiment à le pousser dans ses derniers
retranchements jusqu'au bout non mais
t'es pas l'internet n'est pas loin oui
et non mais je sais mais après encore
une fois c'est le problème ce ne fut pas
loin sur pendant net on ne sait pas deux
heures mais bon c'est sur trois heures
il faut être pas loin tu as inventé as
tu en as moi j'ai toujours écouté un peu
supporters à la fin des matchs du coup
c'est pour ça que j'ai choisi balou et
tout mais mais du coup non mais tu nous
a fait plaisir et
et franchement c'était cool et tu te
rapproches quoi chaque match j'ai
l'impression que tu te rapproches un peu
et sept matches précédents je m'étais
fait massacrer en 3 + 1 ce qui m'avait
complètement mis ko dans le match
je crois que j'ai perdu 8 un truc du
genre donc là évidemment c'est vrai que
j'avais d'ailleurs je pense que c'est
peut-être le premier match où j'ai
épisodiquement eu des monnaies bon
malheureusement ça demandait emprunt
c'est vrai que si j'avais pu mener de
deux points à un moment dans le match ça
aurait peut-être peut-être changer la
donne aurait peut-être été plus calme
ensuite lire la suite du match
ouais écoute dur quoi mais mon l'année
prochaine j'espère qu'il y aura un
nouveau speech est ce n'est pas encore
cette annonce et fins pas encore été
annoncée et j'espère qu'il y aura une
nouvelle compétition est peut-être le
jouer en finale cette fois ci l'éviter
un petit peu et puis fou oui après de
toute façon les autres adversaires
veulent une année de toute façon lui qui
m'a éliminé c'est sacha donc c'est pas
comme si d autres adversaires étaient
des écrivains oui il ya des peut-être
des parties de tableau un peu un peu
moins corsée à windhof c'est comme ça
bien sûr bah c'est sûr que feront take
arous et c'est encore une fois par
magnus ont fait pas plus de jeu plus
difficiles
oui mais non mais t'as pas t'as pas eu
la bonne partie de tableau comme ça quoi
c'est comme ça c'était une fille une
finale avant la fin vous étiez les deux
plus forts à rester est bon je te pose
dernière question what we à moins que tu
vas y sommes enfin sur quelque chose de
nouveau ça vient je n'aime que tu as
faim et que tu as envie de te souviens
j'ai déjà mangé j'ai mangé avant le
match pour s'être mémoire fait non mais
juste dans vas-y autant hikaru est
probablement le plus fort après je suis
pas du tout sûr d'être le deuxième plus
fort du du tableau surtout que bon je
suis internet je joue quand même moins
bien qu'en vrai qu'en live en ce 4 monde
à paris car où justement
mais bon ça reste quand même pas ma
spécialité lobé sur internet tu joues
plus tu joues mieux en bas en réel mais
c'est vrai que grande geste aurait tout
ça on a vu qu un chef
ça donne pas envie de te jouer
honnêtement tu vois c'est
j'ai vite fait ce qu'il faut trop bien
et du coup ça me permet de faire
transition pour aider la question du
coup tu m'as tu l'a amené parce que la
question c'est est ce que tu as vu les
performances de duda dans les matchs de
ce pitch s ouais ouais est cependant à
penser du coup voyez je n'ai pas tout vu
mais j'ai vu que c'était intéressant il
avait des bancaires il a réussi quand
même à ajustement retourner des
situations quand même très compliqué
numériquement je veux dire son match
contre sacha était chaud du début à la
fin je veux dire c'était c'est un peu
comme au match contre hikaru je veux
dire les deux premières heures de mon
match contre hikaru c'était vraiment ce
à l'aide d'un côté de l'autre
après voilà qu'on gêne je pense que non
ce serait intéressant c'est vrai que
j'aurais du mal à prédire un vainqueur
après j'ai envie de dire que les bonnes
à mon sens est meilleur que que les deux
donc voilà mais c'est lui qui doit
affronter en demi finale et que tu
penses que il a qu'il aurait une chance
contre hikaru à duda non non je vais
être honnête au moins au moins tu ne
fasses le suspect non mais tu as raison
de répondre ce que tu as fait les yeux
doux avec leur décès devant le mans qui
a toujours et j'ai envie de voir un
match intéressant mais je pense que il
ya juste pas photo après oui invitation
bien sûr mais bon après tout a été
tellement surprenant déjà contre carrier
qui nous pensaient qu'il avait aucune
chance contre gritche non plus voilé
mais encore une fois bon alors il échoue
je sais pas mais kaya qui n'y joue
évidemment moins bien sur internet quand
la ftc évident non mais c'est sûr que
coûte
on verra bien comment ça se passe maxime
écoute en tout cas merci merci beaucoup
pour toutes les émotions que nous a fait
vivre que ce soit ici aux olympiades et
tout ça c'est toujours un plaisir de
suivre tes parties et tu nous fais
toujours bien kiffé eh ben on espère que
tu continues ton chemin et que tu fous
tu continues à monter pour kung fu la
plus en plus des mots de fer qui fait
avec plus de constance
ouais mais t'inquiète pas tu peux faire
les candidats au site me fait kiffer
enfin tout le temps en fait un des plus
gagné un truc en fait c'est cool donc le
goût de gagner ce que tu veux on est
toujours heureux
bonne soirée repose repose toi bien
si jal est tentant merci cha cha rumba
cha ou les tontons ces mots de la fin du
mois